GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY
WELCOME TO THE ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE.
WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED TODAY
WE HAVE A QUORUM. THE CLERK
THIS CALL ROOM THREE. A. HUESO
PRESIDENT WAS A PRESENT
MOORLACH PRESENT MORE LIKE
PRESENT BRADFORD. EFFORT HERE
CHIANG DIED. DIED HERE
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HERE HEALTH
HILL HERE MCGUIRE WITH RADIO
SKINNER STERN WIENER PRESENT
WIENER PRESENT OKAY. WE'RE
GONNA DO SOME LITTLE BIT OUT OF
THE ORDINARY I'M GONNA START
WITH PRESENTING. MY BILL TODAY
WHICH IS SB SIX OH FIVE. I ALSO
WANT TO ANNOUNCE IN CASE THE
PUBLIC IS NOT AWARE- ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB TWO OR THREE. OF
BY SENATOR BRADFORD HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE AGENDA IT'S
BEEN BEING HELD IN COMMITTEE.
I'M JOKING IT'S A CONSENT ITEM.
YOU WANT A MOMENT LET'S GO
AHEAD AND MOVE IT. I AM SB TWO
OH THREE BRADFORD DO YOU PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WES SELF BY
WES SO I MORE A LOT MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD. NUMBER HANFORD I
ATE CHIANG DIED DODD AYE
HERTZBERG. HILL AYE HILL AYE
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN WIENER AYE WIENER
AYE. SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN I'LL BE PRESENTING MY
BILL MISTER VICE CHAIR IF YOU
CAN PLEASE. YOU WILL WORK I
THOUGHT MAYBE SENATOR BRADFORD
WOULD LIKE TO HANDLE IT. AFTER
THAT LITTLE STUNT. YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU.
OKAY. I'D LIKE TO PRESENT SB
SIX OH FIVE IT'S A BILL THAT
WILL MAKE MINOR CHANGES TO HELP
SPEED UP THE PROCEEDINGS AT THE
CPUC WHILE PRESERVING THE
PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT WE'VE HAD. MANY
CONCERNS THAT THE. THE REVIEW
PROCESS OF THE P. YOU SEE OFTEN
TAKES UP A LOT OF TIME AND-
THERE ARE DELAYS AND IT'S- OF
VERY BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS OF
WE'VE HEARD FOR SEVERAL YEARS
WHILE I'VE BEEN HERE SO WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS THAT WE
CAN- SPEED THAT UP AND GIVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY TO THE CPU
SEEING HOW THEY- ADDRESSED
THEIR PROCEEDINGS THESE ARE OF.
A NORMALLY IF YOU SEE HAS
FORMAL JUDICIAL PROCESS SEES
AND- IN THAT THEY EVALUATE A
VARIETY OF REQUEST RELATED TO
THE INDUSTRIES THAT THE CQC
REGULATES THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR WOULD NO LONGER
REQUIRE IN STATURE TO PRE
HEARING CONFERENCE FOR RE
PROCEEDING OF PRE HEARING
CONFERENCES WILL STILL BE
ALLOWED OR THOUGH STILL TAKE
PLACE BUT THEY WON'T BE- INS IN
STATUTE NOT EVERY. APPLICATION
WOULD NECESSARILY NEEDS A PRE
HEARING CONFERENCE SO THIS
WOULD REMOVE ONE- EXTRA STEP
THAT CURRENTLY TAKE PLACE
WHETHER IT IS A NECESSARY NOT.
THESE PARTIES WOULD CONTINUE TO
BE AFFORDED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WAY N. CAN STILL REQUEST A PRE
HEARING **** CONFERENCE BUT IT
IS NO LONGER A WILL NO LONGER
BE. OF FORMALITY THAT IS SET IN
STATUTE. THE CPUC HAS MENTIONED
IN SOME PROCEEDINGS SOME THAT
WE'VE HAD HERE. THAT THE. THE
TIME AND RESOURCES MAY NOT BE
NECESSARY WHEN I'M PARTY
ATTENDS A PRE HEARING
CONFERENCE AS IS THE CASE CAN
BE IN RAILROAD CROSSING
PROCEEDINGS FOR EXAMPLE
OFTENTIMES A PRE HEARING
CONFERENCE WHEN ONE IS NOT.
NECESSARILY EVEN HELPFUL IN
THAT PROCESS THIS BILL LOS
REQUEST LET LANGUAGE RELATED TO
THE EXISTING QUIET PERIODS
WHERE NO ORAL OR WRITTEN EXPERT
TAKE COMMUNICATIONS ARE ALLOWED
AND WHERE COMMISSIONERS CAN
MEET IN CLOSED SESSIONS ONLY
UNSPECIFIED PROCEEDINGS- WE HAD
TO SEE YOU SEE- WITH THEY WERE
GONNA COME AND SPEAK ON THIS
BUT THEY COULD MAKE IT ON TIME
SO. I REQUEST MY BOAT THAT'S.
THANK YOU SENATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY WHAT IS IN SUPPORT OF.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATT
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK- WE
WORKED WITH- PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION STAFF ON THIS
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT IT'S
CONSISTENT. GOALS OF THE
REFORMS PREVIOUSLY ADOPTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE- AND THAT- THAT
ARE LIKELY TO EXPEDITE SOME
PROCEEDINGS WHERE THERE'S NO
CONTESTED DISPUTES- WITHOUT
DOING HARM TO THE ABILITY OF
PARTIES TO FULLY PARTICIPATE SO
WE SUPPORT THE BILL. ANY OTHER
WITNESS REPORT. DO I HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. JUST
GO AHEAD AND LINE UP. ALL THE
WAY TO THE BACK OF THE ROOM AT.
STARTING BY THE MICROPHONE. HI
WILL ABRAMS- I AM HERE FOR
ANOTHER MATTER BUT I DID WANT
TO SPEAK TO THIS I AM A PARTY
TOO MANY THE CPC PROCEEDINGS-
AS AN INDIVIDUAL- AND I WOULD
SAY THAT I WOULD JUST CAUTION-
DESTRUCTIVE- DISREGARDING THE
PRE HEARING CONFERENCES THEY
ARE OFTEN TIMESTHE ONLY
OPPORTUNITY SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
WANT TO- GO THROUGH THE OTHER
REGULATORY HOOPS TO GET ENGAGE
IN THESE PROCESS SEES AND THE
PRE HEARING CONFERENCES OFTEN
DO SET THE STAGE FOR HOW ARE
THINGS PROCEED AND WHILE LAW
WHICH- INTERVENOR IS LIKE TURN-
HAVE MANY RESOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO APPLY AND- MANY ATTORNEYS TO
BE ABLE TO ARRIVE- PRODUCE.
THINGS JULES LET MYSELF WHO
WANT INDIGENES PROP FOUND THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ARE
OPEN IN THE HE BRINGS IT IN IF
WE WANT TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME
AB ARE BUSY DAYS YOU ARE RIGHT
MOTIONS AND DO THINGS LIKE THAT
SO FOR JUST CAUTION DOES THIS
THING THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR
TELLING SENATOR BRADFORD HAS
TWELVE QUESTIONS THE SAME. ANY
ANYONE ELSE HAVE QUESTIONS- MY
COLLEAGUES WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE BILL- ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION. OF MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. KNOW HOW
TO WIN A CLOSE AFTER WHAT HE
DID IS SENATOR BRADFORD I DON'T
THINK. WELL I GIVEN THE OPTION
THAT. I'D LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SB SIX OH
FIVE TO PASS YOUR PREPARATIONS
WEST SOUTH I WAS SO I MOORLACH
MORE LIKE I BRADFORD. BRADFORD
AYE CHIANG DIED. DODD AYE
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE HILL
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SKINNER STERN WIENER.
WIENER AYE
. VERY WELL TRAVELED
HERE FROM LAST YEAR WE
. I THANK
YOU- TO THE CHAIR AND TO
MEMBERS FOR HEARING THIS BILL
TODAY AND I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH US ON THE BILL-
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT ALL OF
THE AMENDMENTS- THE CHAIR HAS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US- AND BECAUSE IT ALSO
WON A TOAST. NOTE ON THAT THIS
LEGISLATION YOU MAY RECALL I
PUT THIS BILL AND THE PRINCE IN
SEPTEMBER AT THE VERY END OF
SESSION AND I DID THAT VERY
INTENTIONALLY BECAUSE I DIDN'T
WANT TO COME BACK AND DROP- A
SIGNIFICANT BILL IN AND THEN
HAVE TO HAVE A MOVE QUICKLY- WE
WANTED TO GIVE THE ENTIRE FALL
FOR. YOU KNOW STAKEHOLDERS TO
LOOK AT IT AND GIVE FEEDBACK WE
DID RECEIVE QUITE A BIT OF
FEEDBACK OVER THE FALL AND WE
MADE AMENDMENTS LAST WEEK AND
NOW WE'RE TAKING IS FURTHER
AMENDMENTS A WILSON OF THIS IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS AND THAT
BLACKOUTS. AND BLACKOUTS ARE A
HUGE ISSUE- THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THAT THEY WILL
BE PART OF THE CONVERSATION- IN
OUR THE WORKING GROUP THAT
WE'VE ESTABLISHED IN THE SENATE
AS WELL AS ALL OF OUR
CONVERSATIONS UP WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S WE KNOW THIS WILL BE
A CONTINUING CONVERSATION ABOUT
SB THREE SEVEN A I THINK IS A
GOOD FAITH. EFFORT TO TRY TO
GRAPPLE WITH THESE GALS THAT
ARE HAVING A HORRENDOUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA- WE'VE SEEN THAT-
IN- GINNY TERRITORY OF COURSE
IN MOST DRAMATIC FORM OF
BLACKOUT AFFECTING ABOUT. A
HALF MILLION PEOPLE. SEEN IT
CALIFORNIA WELL. I'M MORE CLEAR
I'M NOT AGAINST PLANNED PLANNED
BLACKOUTS AS A GENERAL MATTER
THEY CAN BE A VERY USEFUL TOOL
PARTICULARLY- FOR UTILITIES
LIKE P. GINNY THAT HAVE ALLOWED
THEIR SYSTEM TO DETERIORATE SO
BADLY THAT'S CAUSING A HUGE
WILDFIRE RISK WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER WHAT THE ROOT CAUSES
YOU TO IN A THE FAILURE TO
MAINTAIN INFRASTRUCTURE- BUT IT
ISN'T UNTIL WE CAN GET THAT
TURNED AROUND PLAN BLACKOUTS
SHOULD BE ONE TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX. BUT THE CHALLENGE THAT
WE FACE AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN-
PARTICULARLY WITH P. GINNY BUT
NOT JUST. ANY IS THAT THERE IS
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO ERR ON
THE SIDE OF BROADER BLACKOUTS-
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE
UTILITIES- IN A- AT THE COST OF
DOING A BLOCK OF THERE'S A COST.
BUT I IS NOT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO INCORPORATE ALL OF THE COSTS
THAT THE UTILITY IS INFLICTING
ON THE POP IN GENERAL
POPULATION. THE ONLY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THEIR OWN COST BENEFIT
BALANCE FOR THE UTILITY ITSELF.
AND THE UTILITY DOES NOT EVEN
HAVE TO OTHER THAN THROUGH
POLITICAL PRESSURE. THE UTILITY
DOES NOT HAVE TO PAY ANY
ATTENTION. TO THE COST AND THE
HARMS INFLICTED ON PEOPLE AND
THOSE COSTS ARE REAL IT'S NOT
JUST AN INCONVENIENCE RIGHT
THAT YOU CAN'T WATCH YOU KNOW
CABLE TV OR YOU OR IF YOU DON'T
HAVE BATTERIES YOU CAN'T LISTEN
TO YOUR RADIO OR YOU. YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T YOU KNOW PLUG IN YOUR
FOOT MASSAGER IT'S NOT JUST
CONVENIENCES. THIS IS ABOUT
LIFE OR DEATH IN A LOT OF
SITUATION WHEN WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE WHEN A YOU KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MEDICAL DEVICES
THEY HAVE TO PLUG IN OR THEY
HAVE REFRIGERATED MEDICATION-
AND THAT IS A LIFE OR DEATH
SITUATION. WE KNOW ABOUT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY PROBLEMS THAT
HAPPENED WHEN THE LIGHTS GO OUT.
AND UNTIL PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IN A
BLACKOUT NOT JUST THESE BUT
BLACKOUTS IN GENERAL. IT
CREATES HUGE PUBLIC SAFETY
CHALLENGES IN PEOPLE'S OWN
HOMES. BUT ALSO IN THE
COMMUNITY OR FOR TRAFFIC OR FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY AGENCIES A HUGE
PROBLEM- IT CREATES A HUGE
ECONOMIC PROBLEMS WHEN
BUSINESSES. CLOSE DOWN SMALL
BUSINESSES BIG BUSINESSES AND
FOR MANY SMALL BUSINESSES IN
PARTICULAR CLOSING DOWN FOR
THREE OR FOUR DAYS. THAT COULD
BE WHAT PUSHES YOU- INTO
BANKRUPTCY. MANY THESE
BUSINESSES AE OPERATING ON
SMALL MARGINS THEY HAVE NO
MARGIN FOR ERROR AND WE'RE
SHUTTING THEM DOWN AND WE KNOW
BECAUSE THAT I'VE HEARD FROM
BUSINESSES IN MY DISTRICT HER
TERRIFIED THAT THE AND THEIR
INSURANCE DOESN'T EVEN COVER.
THE LOST. PROFITS ARE LOST
REVENUES FROM THESE BLACKOUTS
BECAUSE IT WAS NOT UNEXPECTED
QUOTE ON QUOTE BECAUSE THEY GOT
TWENTY FOUR OR FORTY EIGHT
HOURS NOTICE. IT'S A HUGE
HARDSHIP FOR FAMILIES WHEN
PEOPLE CAN'T EITHER CAN'T GO TO
WORK AND CAN EARN A LIVING
BECAUSE YOU'RE BUSINESSES SHUT
DOWN. OR YOU HAVE TO STAY HOME
BECAUSE YOUR KIDS SCHOOL IS
SHUT DOWN BECAUSE IT HAS NO
POWER AND SO YOU CAN GO TO WORK
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO STAY HOME
WITH YOUR KIDS. WE KNOW THAT
FOR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS. THE
US TOMORROW SMALL NOBLE
COMMUNITIES- IT IS A MAJOR
HARDSHIP. MISSING A FEW DAYS A
WORK- IS A HUGE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP. BUT LOSING ALL THE
CONTENTS OF YOUR REFRIGERATOR
FOR MANY OF US WE HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SAYING YOU KNOW
WHAT. I DON'T LIKE IT BUT I'M
GONNA GO SHOPPING FOR MORE
FOOD. FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE YOU
LOSE YOUR REFRIGERATOR
CONTENTS. THAT'S YOUR FOOD FOR
THE MONTH. AND SO THESE ARE
HUGE COST AND RIGHT NOW THE
UTILITIES DO NOT HAVE TO TAKE
THAT INTO ACCOUNT I COMMAND
GOVERNOR NEW SOME FOR- FOR
BADGERING. SUCCESSFULLY THE
TILL- YOU NEED TO PAY SOME
MONEY I THINK IT WAS A HUNDRED
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT'S
GREAT BUT WE NEED TO HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN GET COMPENSATION. AND SO SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT TRIES TO
FORCE THE UTILITIES TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT ALL THESE ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS. BY ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
SEE COMPENSATION FOR DAMAGES-
DOT WILL BE DONE THROUGH THE
CPUC- AND PURSUING TOOK A MEMO
WE TOOK FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE'RE GIVING THE CPC
FLEXIBILITY ABOUT SETTING UP
THAT SYSTEM AND WHAT EXACTLY IS
COMPENSATED SO WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MICROMANAGE TO. THE CPC WILL
HAVE SOME LATITUDE TO SET UP-
THAT- THAT SYSTEM. ON IT IN
ADDITION- WILL- THERE WILL BE
AN HOURLY FEE WHICH WE'VE
SCALED BACK UNDER THE
COMMITTEES MEMBERS WITH CUT IN
HALF. AND IT WILL ONLY APPLY IF
THE CPC DETERMINES THAT THE
BLACKOUT WAS UNREASONABLE- SO
WE SCALE THAT BACK I THINK IN
IN AN APPROPRIATE WAY- WE'VE
TAKEN OUT. **** AND ABOUT.
PROHIBITING THE UTILITIES FROM
LOBBYING AGAINST ALTERNATIVE
FORMS OF ENERGY- LIKE PUBLIC
POWER OR DVRS- ALTHOUGH I-
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT I
THINK IT'S OUTRAGEOUS. THAT THE
UTILITIES HAVE I CAN PUT A
STRANGLEHOLD FOR MANY YEARS ON
ALTERNATIVE FORMS OF ENERGY- WE
WERE HOT WE WERE WILLING TO
TAKE THAT OUT BECAUSE THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT. IDEA I COULD
PROBABLY BERKELEY BE ITS OWN-
BUILT ON THE LEGISLATION. ALSO
REQUIRES BETTER DITA. SO THAT
WE KNOW A. SAFI WHAT'S
HAPPENING- WITH THESE OF
BLACKOUTS- AND BECAUSE I JUST
THINK THAT THIS IS A GOOD.
APPROACH AND AGAIN
UNDERSTANDING IT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR BY BOAT. FOUGHT
WITH ME TODAY- ARE- PATRICIA
ROMERO- AUGUST RIVAS OF THE
FOOD BANK OF CAUGHT CONTRA
COSTA AND SOLANO COUNTY. AND
WILL ABRAMS OWNER OF ONE OR WE
CONSULTING- AND ALSO HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS- IS A I'VE
BEEN A CHIANG WITH THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE WHICH IS OUR SPONSOR
OF THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
YEAH AND THE CLOSER. HELLO MY
NAME IS BUT THREE SEVERAL
MADDOG WAS FEVERS SOME FROM
VALLEJO CALIFORNIA- AND I'M
HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHAT
I EXPERIENCED ON THE POWER SHUT
OFF- I DID EXPERIENCE THE POWER
SET OFF SITE WAS OUT OF POWER
FOR ABOUT FOUR AND A HALF DAYS
ON LOST. ALL THE CONTENTS OF MY
FREE TRADER AND FREEZER- AND-
JUST AS A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY
ABOUT MYSELF I'M ON A FIXED
INCOME I'M ON SOCIAL SECURITY
RETIREMENT AND THAT'S MY ONLY
FORM OF INCOME. FOR ME TO GO
OUT AND BUY GROCERIES AFTER
I'VE LOST EVERYTHING AND AFTER
I'VE PAID FOR GROCERIES FOR THE
MONTH. BECAME A COMPLETE. ON ME
IT WAS A HARDSHIP ON ME- IT
WITHOUT THE HELP OF THE FOOD
BANK WHICH I AM ALSO AN
ADVOCATE FOR THE FOOD BANK.
WITHOUT THE HELP FROM THE FOOD
BANK I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SURVIVE. I HAVE OLD ELDERLY
PARENTS THAT LIVE ABOUT FOUR
AND A HALF BLOCKS AWAY FROM ME
FROM UP IN AMERICAN CANYON MY
MOM IS ON INSULIN HER INSULIN
HAS TO BE REFRIGERATED. SO WHEN
I LOST MY POWER FIRST OF ALL.
P. GINNY HAD NOTIFIED VIA THE-
TV THAT THEY WRE GOING TO BE
POWER OUTAGES. THE FIRST POWER
OUTAGE IN THE BEGINNING OF
NORTH OF OCTOBER I WAS IT. I
DIDN'T GET A HIT BY THOSE. IT
WAS THE SECOND ONE WHERE I WAS
OUT FOR LIKE I SAID FOUR AND A
HALF DAYS. I GOT. AS SOON AS MY
POWER WENT OUT I GOT A
NOTIFICATION. THAT WAS MY
NOTIFICATION YOUR POWERS OUT A
YEAH I KNOW. IF I COULD SEE I
HAVE NO NO LIGHT IN THE HOUSE-
AND I DID I WAS ABLE TO CONTACT
PGD AFTER IT CAME BACK ON IT I
WAS ABLE TO CONTACT AND ASKED
THEM ABOUT ANY TYPE OF
REIMBURSEMENT AND THEY TOLD ME.
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET THE REIMBURSEMENT
WERE THE ONES FROM THE
ADDITIONAL POWDER HOUR OUTAGE
BECAUSE THEIR WEBSITE WAS DOWN
AND THEY COULDN'T NOTIFY PEOPLE
AND I GOT MY NOTIFICATION. WELL
I GOT IT THE DAY I GOT I GOT
HIT OKAY- AND I HAVE TO. FIGURE
OUT WHAT AM I GOING TO DO TO
SAVE MY CONTENT SO I COULDN'T
FIND ANY PLACE THAT HAD ICE IN
MY COMMUNITY I HAD TO DRIVE OUT
TO FAIRFIELD TO GET ICE TO PUT
MY- MY FOOD. IN ICE CHESTS SO I
CAN HAVE YOU KNOW I CAN HAVE MY
FOOD STATE AND UNFORTUNATELY
THE SECOND DAY- SO I WAS ABLE
TO GET TWENTY BAG THE ICE I
SHARED SOME WITH MY PARENTS
SHARE SOME WITH WITH MYSELF AND
A COUPLE OF NEIGHBORS THAT ARE
ELDERLY GAVE THEM SOME ICE. BUT
THE SECOND DAY WHEN THERE WAS
NO MORE ICE I WAS LIKE OKAY
GONNA LOSE AT ALL SO I STARTED
I HAVE A GAS STOVE SO I WAS
ABLE TO COOK ON TOP OF MY GUESS
SO I COULD WHAT I COULD COOK
AND I FELT A COUPLE PEOPLE. YOU
KNOW MY NEIGHBORHOOD THAT HAD
ELECTRIC HAD ELECTRIC
APPLIANCES AND THEN THE REST OF
THE FOOD WENT SO NOW HERE I AM
THE POWERS BACK ON I HAVE TO GO
TO THE GROCERY STORE. AND I'VE
GOT TO BUY GROCERIES AND I
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY. SO WHAT
DO YOU DO. YOU KNOW WHAT DO YOU
DO AND THEN AFTER I STARTED
THINKING ABOUT. OKAY WHAT CAN I
DO TO PREVENT THIS WELL I COULD
GET A GENERATOR BUT I DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY FOR THAT EITHER
SO- PEOPLE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO BUY A GENERATOR SO
THEY COULD SAVE THE FOOD THAT
THEY PAID THAT THEY PAID FOR.
WHAT DO YOU DO. AND ALSO I HAVE
AND I STARTED THINKING AGAIN
OKAY WHAT DO I DO IN THE FUTURE
I STARTED REALIZING IN MY HOME
MY SMOKE DETECTORS ARE. EAST
WIRED INTO MY HOUSE SO DURING
THAT TIME FRAME HAD. THERE BEEN
A FIRE IN MY HOME I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN- NOTIFIED THROUGH MY
FIRED MY SMOKE DETECTORS
BECAUSE THEY'RE ELECTED BASED
SO THAT MEANS OKAY I NEED A
GENERATOR NOW I NEED TO GO OUT
AND BUY SMOKE DETECTORS WHICH I
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY FOR AS
WELL AS GROCERIES. SO IT'S
THAT'S HOW IT'S HIT ME YOU KNOW
EN. I CAN'T I DON'T KNOW IF I
CAN AFFORD TO GO THROUGH THIS
AGAIN WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO
IN THE NEXT ONE. THANK YOU
MA'AM THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DID
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER IT SIR. OUR
THANKS. WILLIE BROWN'S- OWNER
OF ONE ARE WE- PRIOR TO THE
FIRES OF TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN- MY CONSULTING
SERVICES FOCUSED ON TELECOM AND
TECH- SINCE RUNNING FROM THE
FLAMES IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN. AND BE MOVING VERY
COGNIZANT OF THE ISSUES THAT
SURROUND THIS IVORY FOCUSED. MY
EFFORTS ON- TRYING TO HELP
WHERE I CAN. IN TERMS OF THE
PATH FORWARD IN RECOVERY AND
RESILIENCY- THESE POWER SHUT
OFFS- HAVE LARGELY AFFECTED
BUSINESSES IN THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY- YOU'LL SHIFTING. THE
RISKS. OF A WILDFIRE FROM
UTILITIES TO. INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES- IS NOT. THE RIGHT
WAY TO PROCEED- I THINK THAT
THERE ARE MANY BUSINESSES WHO
ARE STRUGGLING- FOR MYSELF I
LOST POWER SIX TIMES- I DO LIVE
IN THE WILD LIFE FOR URBAN
INTERFACE BUT I THINK ONE OF
THE- MISS NUMBERS ABOUT THAT IS
THAT YOU THINK ABOUT. THE
WILDLIFE FOR INTERVENTION IT
WILDLIFE INNER. URBAN HER FACE.
AS IF IT'S OFF INTO THE
WILDERNESS. I LIVE IN SANTA
ROSA. SO PRETTY. PRETTY AYE
SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA. AND LOST POWER SIX
TIMES- KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL. FOR
TWO AND A HALF WEEKS. AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW I'M
GONNA- ORGANIZE MY WORK DAY.
AROUND THAT. AND IN. IN
RESPONSE TO THAT TOO AND- DAYS
OF MISS SCHOOL- THEY GET HALF
DAY. OF IT BACK FOR. THAT TIME
UP- BUSINESSES ARE STRUGGLING
TO FIND GENERATORS. SHIFTING
ARE RISKS. FROM UTILITIES WHO
ARE THE EXPERTS IN THIS TO.
VISUAL BUSINESSES TO FIRE UP.
THE RAIDERS AND FIGURE OUT ALL
THOSE THINGS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR BUSINESSES ARE. EVEN
THOUGH COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE. IS
NOT NECESSARILY. A FOR THE
PUBLIC. I'M I WOULD SAY THAT
PART OF WHAT I'VE BEEN DOING
IT- THROUGH THIS IS TRYING TO
REACH OUT TO OTHER BUSINESS
OWNERS TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS. ARE EVER
CENTER IS A IS A LARGE RETAIL
OPERATION IN SANTA ROSA- I KNOW
THE OWNERS OF UPPER CENTER AND
THEY HAVE EXPRESSED TO ME THAT
THESE POWER SHUT OFFS COSTS
THEM. A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS DURING THIS- SHUT OFF
TIME- AND THEY HAD THEIR POWER
ON. AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE EVACUATED.
AND SO MANY PEOPLE I CHOSE TO
STAY AT HOME BECAUSE OF- THE
SITUATION THAT THEY LOST
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE. SO WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THE IMPLICATIONS
NOT JUST FOR THOSE WHO LOSE
POWER BUT FOR THOSE BUSINESSES
THAT HAVE POWER STILL ON AND
THE EFFECTS OF THAT IN THE
COMMUNITY- I WOULD SAY IF I
CAN'T VERY QUICKLY- THAT ARE
THROUGH THE CPUC. IN MIND JOINT
ERROR- AND IN THE PRECEDING
RELATED TO THE POWER SHUT OFF
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT CAN
BE DONE AND I THINK THE BIG
THING THAT. BILL DOES IN THAT I
SUPPORT IS THAT THE UTILITIES
FIND SHEL SUCCESS. NEEDS TO BE
TIED TO OUR SUCCESS. AND THAT
HAS BEEN LARGELY MISSING FROM
THE EQUATION. AND ALTHOUGH
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT HOW
UTILITIES ARE LOOKING OUT FOR
PUBLIC INTERESTS. AND LESS IT
IS TIED TO THEIR BOTTOM LINE
INTERESTS. IT WON'T HAVE A PATH
FORWARD- I JUST WANTED TO ALSO
STATE THAT I'M ALSO CLAIM IT IN
THE P. JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDING- AND I KNOW MANY
HAVE FOCUSED ON THAT AS- PLEASE
FOR RESTRUCTURING PACIFIC GAS
AND ELECTRIC THAT IS NOT
OCCURRING THERE- AND THE VOICE
OF THE PUBLIC IN THAT
PROCEEDING I'VE- BEEN TRYING TO
ARGUE IN FAVOR. OF THE
GOVERNOR'S LETTER AND THE
STRONG SENTIMENT THAT HE
EXPRESSED- IN THAT PROCEEDING
OUT TO MAKE SURE THAT P. GENIES
RESTRUCTURED UNFORTUNATELY THE
LARGE FINANCIAL INTERESTS THAT
MAKE UP THE PARTIES IN THAT
ROOM ARE PUSHING AGAINST THAT.
AND I WOULD JUST URGE- EVERYONE
IN THIS ROOM TO PLEASE SUPPORT
THAT EFFORT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PUBLIC INTERESTS ARE ALSO
REPRESENTED THERE- I WON'T GO
INTO DETAIL BUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THINGS IN. THE RSA
THEIR STRUCTURE A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THAT PUSH US IN
ABSOLUTELY THE WRONG DIRECTION
AND GIVEN THE DEADLINE THAT'S
FAST APPROACHING IT IS A
CONCERN ALL OF THESE ISSUES
RELATE AND HEART WENT OFF TOPIC
I APOLOGIZE. BUT THE POINT IS
ALL OF THESE ISSUES RELATE LIKE
YOU SIR THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MR MEMBERS HUNDRED FROM
IT AS ON BEHALF OF THE TRI
VALLEY CITIES OF DUBLIN
DANVILLE PLEASANTON LIVERMORE
IN SAN RAMON AS WELL AS THE
CITY OF OAKLAND AND BERKELEY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE
MORNING EDITION CALIFORNIA
MISSION OF FOOD BANKS CAMPAñA
BETTER THAN PATRICIA AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. TO THE
COMING BATES FOOD BANK OF
CONTRA COSTA AND SOLANO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MARK FENSTER
MAKER FOR VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY
IN SUPPORT. IT'S NOT YOUR
HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF TURN WE
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF THE
BILLS OF THE PRINCIPLES AND WE
LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. THE COMMITTEE ON THE
BILL GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR CHASE LACQUERED
WITH ADULTS TING GILBERT
ROBESON SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER REPRESENTING ON
THE COUNTY ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. TO HAVE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. YOUR BUDGET. GOT
TO GO UP THE- PLEASE IF YOU CAN
CLEAR SPACE FOR THIS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE MEMBER SCOTT WHAT
SHOULD BE AT THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I LIKE TO
THINK THE COMEDIAN THE AUTHOR-
THE MINUTES THAT WERE TAKEN.
WERE I THINK ARE VERY
RESPONSIBLE AND MOVED TO BUILD
A MUCH BETTER DIRECTION. ON THE
LAST PIECE OF THE BILL THAT WAS
THE TOPIC IN THE DISCUSSION.
WE'RE WAITING TO SEE WHAT COMES
FROM THIS COMMITTEE IN THE FORM
OF ANY AMENDMENTS BUT- WE STILL
HAVE. SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST. IT SEEKS TO
PLACE NEW PENALTIES FINANCIAL
DISINCENTIVES TO WE BELIEVE
ACTING RESPONSIBLE- WIN THE P.
YOU SEE HAS STILL NOT EVEN
ISSUE RULES. YOU SHOULD BE
FIGHTING MICHAEL PICKER RIGHT
NOW. IT'S BEEN A YEAR AND A
HALF THERE'S NO RULES THEY HAVE
AN ADOPTED A RULE PACKAGE YET
ON WHAT THE STANDARDS AND
PROTOCOLS FOR DOING A SHUT OFF
BE THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS. THAT
SHOULD BE DEALT WITH BEFORE YOU
START DEALING WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR NOT FOLLOWING
THE RULES THAT HAVE NOT EVEN
BEEN SET YET. AND THEN SECONDLY
MY I'M A THIRD GENERATION
SONOMA COUNTY IT I HAD.
NUMEROUS FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
WERE EVACUATED IN THIS LAST
FIRES OF THE COUNTY FOR UP TO
EIGHT DAYS. I WOULD TELL YOU IF
YOU ASKED ANY OF THEM WOULD YOU
RATHER BE. WITHOUT POWER FOR
FIVE OR SIX DAYS. OR WITHOUT
SHELTER BECAUSE OF FIRES IS
BARRELING DOWN ON YOU THEY
WOULD TO A PERSON SAY I'D
RATHER HAVE SHELTER SO WE WILL
CAUTIOUSLY WATCH WHAT COMES OUR
COMMITTEE TODAY CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR BUT- WE
DON'T THINK THE BILL'S STANCE.
TODAY IS READY TO BE PASSED
THANKS. ADAM SMITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSING SB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT- ESSIE RECOGNIZES THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF SO
DISRUPTIVE THEY CAN BE A
HARDSHIP ESPECIALLY IF I'M
PREPARED. SO WE STRIVE TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OUR
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITIES WE DO
NOT MAKE THE DECISION TO POWER
DOWN LIGHTLY. AND WHEN WE DO
POWER DOWN WE DO IT IN A VERY
TARGETED WAY THANKS TO YEARS OF
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE HELPED TO
SECTION LIES OUR GRID. WHEN WE
CONDUCT A P. S. P. S. OF AND IT
SERVES A VERY VITAL PURPOSE
IT'S NECESSARY TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S FROM CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. IN FACT S. C.
PATROLS CONDUCTED AFTER THE
OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN SHUT
OFFS. FOUND SEVERAL INSTANCES
OF EQUIPMENT DAMAGE AND TREE
BRANCHES CONTACTING PARALYZES
THE PUBLIC REPORT I'M HOLDING
UP AND HAVING DESCENDED TO YOUR
OFFICES. JUST FOR A TEN DAY
WINDOW IN OCTOBER THAT
HIGHLIGHTS BROKEN CROSS ARMS
FOUND BY OUR OUR CREWS- WIND
THAT BLEW ON OWNING INTO A
SERVICE LINE TREES IN THE LINES
REMOVED WE DID. BUT THEY DIDN'T
AND THAT'S PRECISELY BECAUSE
SCA EMPLOYEES DE ENERGIZED
THOSE LINES PREEMPTIVELY AND
TOOK THE TIME TO REPAIR THEM
SAFELY. WE'VE SPENT THE LAST
TWO YEARS AS A STATE DEFINING
IN SHAPING WHAT PRUDENT UTILITY
OPERATIONS SHOULD LOOK LIKE IN
THIS ERA OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
RISING WILDFIRE RISK. SB NINE A
ONE ADDRESSED IT THE NINE A ONE
COMMISSION ADDRESSED IT AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR ADDRESSED IT. IS I
THINK MISTER WEST MENTIONED
ONGOING PC PROCEEDINGS AND RULE
MAKINGS AND GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS
NOW WE HAVE A BILL WITH SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS IMPRINT BUT AS IT
LOOKS TODAY WE THINK WOULD FIND
UTILITIES FOR ACTING PRUDENTLY.
EVEN WITH THE CONCEPTUAL
COMMITTEE AMEND. HE THINKS THAT
THE WRONG. DESTRUCTION
PENALIZES US WHEN WE DO THE
RIGHT THING TO KEEP THE PUBLIC
SAFE RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING
DIANA FLEMING'S ON BEHALF OF
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY WE ALSO OPPOSE. SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT- I WOULD
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MANY OF MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE RAISED BY
MY COLLEAGUE AT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON BUT I WILL
JUST MAKE ONE POINT. WE VIEW AT
PGA P. JEANNIE WE'VE YOU DE
ENERGIES ATION FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY IS BUT ONE IS SHORT TERM
SOLUTION TO PROTECT OUR
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITIES. P.
GENIE IS WORKING HRD EVERY DAY
TO IMPLEMENT ADDITIONAL LONG
TERM SOLUTIONS TO REDUCE THE
SIZE THE DURATION AND FREQUENCY
OF POWER SHUT OFF TO MINIMIZE
IMPACTS ON OUR CUSTOMERS. A WE
WILL REVIEW THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHEN THEY'RE PRINT
WE BELIEVE THEY ARE MOVING IN A
BETTER DIRECTION WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBER STILL ANY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE COURT
WE WERE IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. A RELATIVE TO
THE SECTION TWO OF THE BILL
WHICH NOW I UNDERSTAND HAS BEEN
REMOVED PER THE COMMITTEE- I
MINUTES. HOWEVER THE REST OF
THE BILL NOW APPLIES TO PACIFIC
CORE- AND WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING
EXACTLY WHAT THE NEW LANGUAGE
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE TO REMAIN IN
THE POST LAST MINUTE POSITION
UNTIL. FURTHER NOTICE. A MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- HUNTER STERN AYE
BE TO BE TWELVE FORTY FIVE OUR
MEMBERS REPRESENT- OR ARE. MY I
REPRESENT A MEMBER WORKERS AT
P. JEANNIE AS WELL AS WORKERS A
TWENTY EIGHT DIFFERENT A
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES
NORTHERN CENTRAL CLIFORNIA- WE
REMAIN OPPOSED WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR- AND HAVE
BEEN- BUT THERE ARE THREE.
THINGS THAT WE WANT TO PASS
AROUND OUR PASS ALONG FIRST AND
FOREMOST. WERE FULLY AWARE OF
THE HELP OF THE HARDSHIP ON
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. FOR THOSE
YOU HAVE DISTRICTS IN WHICH
THEIR POWER SHUT OFF HAVE
OCCURRED- IT IS A BIG PROBLEM.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE KNOW
THAT BECAUSE OUR MEMBERS ARE
OUT. RECEIVING SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS OR THE FEEDBACK IS A
POLITE TERM. IT'S REALLY ABUSE-
AND IT WE HAD A COUPLE
INSTANCES OF ACTUAL SALT. SO WE
WANT THIS FIXED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
MEMBERS. FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC. AND THEN MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE NEED IT FIXED IN
A COMPREHENSIVE IN FULL WAY. SO
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BILL AND OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE CAN FIX THE
PROBLEM. AROUND CLEAR.
GUIDELINES FOR SAFE. USE OF THE
AGES ATION. OF THE PS PS
PROCESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR IT'S
REAL SALAS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC I WOULD- WE HAVE
BEEN OPPOSE POSITION RELATIVE
TO SECTIONS TWO AND THREE WHICH
WITH THE- COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
ARE COMING OUT SO WE WOULD
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH- THE
COMMENTS ARE THERE BY PACIFIC
CORPS. I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE AS IT RELATES TO US
NOW BEING INCLUDED IN THE P. S.
P. S. RELATED PROVISIONS BEFORE
WE CAN- DECIDE WHAT OUR
POSITION WILL BE GOING FORWARD.
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE.
. YES OVER THERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. I ON BEHALF OF THE
FOURTEEN THOUSAND BUSINESSES
THAT CUT THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE REPRESENTS WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE ENERGY
STATION. HAS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON ALL OF OUR BUSINESSES
AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR- IS LOOKING AT
AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
SAFETY. AND ISN'T IMPACTS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS IN PRINT AND WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHORS
OFFICE TO WORK THERE. THANK YOU
OF. CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF. YOU KNOW I
WAS GONNA I WAS GONNA SAY THIS
IS STRONG AS MISTER WHICH DID
THE CREEK THE NOTION THAT WE
HAVE OPEN PROCEEDINGS AT THE P.
UC WE'VE GOT A GOVERNOR HASN'T
TAKEN A POSITION WE'VE GOT OF
OTHERS OUR OWN SENATE TASK
FORCE WORKING GROUP SOME OF
WHOM ARE HERE TODAY IN THIS
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE YET TO COME
FORWARD IN THIS DEAL. WE HAVE-
YOU KNOW THIS LARGER DYNAMIC
IT'S THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
AND I YOU KNOW I JUST MENTIONED
BECAUSE I ALWAYS MENTION THE
FOR THE ROOM WHICH IS THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF INVERSE CONDEMNATION
AND THEY'RE NOT JUST THE ISSUE
OF THEOBVIOUS SAFETY RISK IN
THE DENERVATION THAT IDEA WAS
BUSTED MISSED WHICH IN TERMS
OF. PEOPLE AND HOW THEIR FAMILY
LIKE FORCES HAVING SOMEONE CAN
BE NO QUESTIONS DIFFICULT BUT
THE WHOLE LARGER DYNAMIC OF
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A WORK
AROUND THIS BIG. ISSUE OF
INVERSE CONDEMNATION YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY THE SAFETY RISK AND
ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS ARE
CRITICAL. BUT ULTIMATELY THE
PEOPLE THE BOARD ROOM DON'T
WANT TO FILE BANKRUPTCY AGAIN
AND ALL OF THOSE ISSUES AGAIN
AS IT SHOULD BE THE ONLY
FACTORS. BUT AGAIN IT'S I ONLY
RAISE THAT WITH YOU IS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW HERE WE ARE WORKING
AROUND THE EDGES NOT LOOKING AT
THE TOUGH ISSUE DIRECTLY IN THE
EYE. AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THAT ASK THOSE QUESTIONS OF
I. SO. LOOK YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS IS I DO APPRECIATE AND
REALIZES AND I APOLOGIZE I
SHOULD HAVE DONE MY HOMEWORK ON
THIS. IS THIS BACK IN SEPTEMBER
WHICH WAS SMART ON YOUR BEHALF-
BUT BUT THE- TICKET IS
PREMATURE I THINK THAT IS A
HOST OF OTHER STUFF GOING ON I
AM AS A- RESPECT FOR THE-
EARNESTNESS IT AND
INTELLIGENCE- AND IMPORTANCE OF
THIS ISSUE TO DOCTOR WILL.
BOARD TODAY RESERVE I WAS IN A
COUPLE WEEKS AWAY BECAUSE THEY
DO BUT MARK WAS OF A NOT TO
VOTE ON THE FLOOR FOR THIS.
ENERGY YOU DESERVE. THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE MAKE A LOT OF. WITH
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE IS
IMPORTANT HERE MAYBE WE CAN
COME TO SOME CONCLUSIONS PART
OF ALL THE PARTIES. I JUST WANT
TO FRAME OUT THE LARGER CONTEXT
AND PUT THAT INTO THE- THE
RECORD BEFORE I. VOTED ON THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS. EXTRA CENTER
RIGHT FOR. THANK YOU AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
COMMITMENT TO TRYING TO SOLVE
ISSUE BUT A ISSUE THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED SHUT OFFS
ARE NOTHING NEW- I SPENT.
TWELVE YEARS OF MY LIFE WORKING
FOR UTILITY COMPANY AND WE RE
TOOLING ROUTINELY SHUT OFF
POWER. THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
TODAY IS THERE LONGER AND
LARGER AREAS BUT- TO REPAIR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO. LET YOU SEE
OB MAKE UPGRADES WE SHUT THE
POWER OFF ON A REGULAR BASIS
AND I WAS CHALLENGE MANY TIMES
YOU GO KNOCK ON DOORS AND HAND
OUT VOTE VOUCHERS FOR FOOD. TO
THE PORTS OF COMMUNITIES WHEN
WE MANAGED TO TURN ON SANTA
MONICA BEVERLY HILLS A WHOLE
LOT QUICKER THAN WE MANAGED TO
TURN ON. COMPTON AND THE
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS AS AS WE'RE
HERE TODAY BECAUSE THIS
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE PS PS. NOT
A SINGLE UTILITY WHETHER IT'S
INVESTOR OWNED OR PUBLIC ALL
WALK IN HERE SEE AND YOU KNOW
SOMETHING WE WANT TO SHUT OFF
POWER TO OUR CUSTOMERS. BUT
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED IN THE
LAST YEAR ASKS WHERE THEY SHUT
OFF POWER THERE WAS CLEAR
CHALLENGES TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE JUST LIKE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON- YOU
SHARED A FEW MINUTES AGO THERE
WERE BRANCHES IN THE LINES.
THERE WERE. TREES THEY WERE THE
BRAVE PALM FRONDS OR WHEN THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES IN A
WINDSTORM TWO EIGHT YOU TILTED
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE BUT A
LOT OF WHAT PEOPLE FAIL TO
UNDERSTAND IS. MANY TIMES THOSE
TREES ARE THERE BECAUSE. PRETTY
AND THE UTILITY CAN ACCESS AND
WE SHOULD OF FOUR DEAD
UTILITIES BETTER ACCESS TO.
ENTERTHESE PROPERTIES BACK
MUCH OF ITS STATE AND FEDERAL
LANDS THAT WE CAN'T THEY CAN'T
GET ON I SHOULD SAY- TO
MAINTAIN AND CUT BACK THE
TREES. AND DEBRIS TO HELP
PREVENT THIS BUT AGAIN. THE
COMMUNITY. AS A WHOLE. LOSES
FAITH AND LEGISLATORS WHEN WE
ASK FOR SOMETHING AND THEN A
COMPANY OR INDUSTRY FOLLOWS
EXACTLY WHAT WE LEGISLATIVE
THEM TO DO AND NOW THEY'RE THE
BAD GUYS. THIS WILL BE PASSED
ON THE RATE PAYERS NO MATTER
HIGH WE FRAME IT REPAIRS AT THE
END OF THE DAY. WILL ALWAYS PAY
FOR ANY OF THIS. WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF- SOONER ARTS BURKE
I RESPECT HIS COMMENT BECAUSE
HE IS THE ONLY ONE HERE. THAT
WAS LATER AND THIS AND THIS IS
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND
ONE I ENERGY CRISIS THAT WAS
CREATED BY HOME THE LEGISLATURE
AGAIN MY BAD POLICY IN THE LATE
EIGHTIES. ASSN FOR DEREGULATION
OF THE IMAGE- UTILITY SECTOR
AND WE'RE GOING TO DO IT AGAIN
FOLKS WERE SETTING THE TABLE UP
FOR ANOTHER ENERGY CRISIS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
THAT REASON. I WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THIS MERGER TODAY.
US UNDER A STERN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR. BACK IN SEPTEMBER JUMPING
INTO THE FRAY HERE WITH ALL THE
REST OF US WHO ARE GOING
THROUGH THE FIGHT- WE HAD WE
DIDN'T LOSE AS MANY HOMES TO
THE POWER OUTAGES AS THEY DID
IN THE NORTH BUT- IT. IT
SQUARELY CENTERED IN THIS SORT
OF IN MY DISTRICT ACTUALLY I
MEAN IN TERMS OF THE BALK AT
THE CUSTOMER'S HIT THROUGH
OCTOBER- AND ALL THE WAY UP TO
MY WEDDING. BUT IT DIDN'T SHUT
OFF MY ENTIRE WEDDING SO THAT
WAS GOOD- BUT LATE GRANDMOTHER
MEANWHILE SIT IN THE DARK FOR
WEEKS ON END. THANK GOD SHE'S
WE GOT A LINE TO HER WE WENT
AND FOUNDER AND EVACUATED HERE
AND GOT HER MEDICINE INTO A
FREE AGENT TODAY ACTUALLY
GENERATORS ON IT. AND MY FAMILY
CAN AFFORD TO PUT ONE IN THERE
AND A LOT OF FAMILIES CAN'T.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF WORKING
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO ARE UPSIDE
DOWN STILL BECAUSE OF THIS SO
ONE QUESTION I HAD JUST AS A
TECHNICAL MATTER IS WHAT
HAPPENS TO. WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE HAVING TO THE
PENALTIES. THEM THESE THAT ARE
COLLECTED THAT THE BILL. IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OF THE
BILL SPEAKS TO. WILL ACTUALLY
GO TO MITIGATE THE HARM TO.
THOSE IMPACTED OR NOT- WANT TO
TOUCH ON THAT YEP ISSUE RIGHT
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE.%
DEDICATION FOR THE FUNDS THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY A TOPIC. WERE
WILLING TO ENGAGE ON- YOU KNOW
OUR HOPE WE THIS IS- ONE OF
THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE WE HOPE
IF YOU NEVER GETS COLLECTED.
RIGHT WE WANNA SORT OF
INCENTIVIZE THE RIGHT BEHAVIOR
AND MY HOPE IS THAT IT. OR IF
IT DOES GET COLLECTED THAT
IT'S- THE MINIMUMS THAT'S MY
HOPE WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE
INCENTIVES- BUT WE'RE OPEN TO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT. WHAT THE
BEST USE OF THOSE FUNDS ARE.
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE NO
WAY OF KNOWING. HELLO LARGE
MALL IT WILL BE. SO SHE THAT
OPEN IS THAT'LL BE IMPORTANT
FOR ME DOWN THE HOME STRETCH OF
THE BILL MAKES IT OUT BECAUSE
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT AT LEAST
EDISON'S PROCESS THAT I FAR AS
FAR AS I UNDERSTAND THEY CAN
CLARIFY BUT I THINK THERE'S A
CLAIMS PROCESS FOR- HOMEOWNERS.
I GUESS HEALTH AND. DIRECT
HARDSHIP BUT NOT FOR BUSINESS
LOSSES SO TO THE CHAMBERS
POINTER THE LARGER IN OF THE
HOTELS THAT WENT UNDER WE HAVE
IN A CITY SMALL CITRUS GROWER
LOST TWO MILLION DOLLARS NOW
HE'S BELLY UP RIGHT SO THOSE
INDUSTRIES I THINK I'VE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND FROM THE CLAIMS
PROCESS IF I'M NOT RIGHT I'M
HAPPY TO BE CORRECTED THERE SO
THAT'LL BE IMPORTANT FOR FUTURE
SUPPORT AND ONE OTHER THING I
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT WAS.
BASHING WITH THE- WITH SENATOR
DODD'S ONE SIXTY SEVEN FROM
LAST YEAR WHICH I THINK. IT IS
ESTABLISHED THIS NEED FOR
UNIFORM PROTOCOL- I THINK THAT
THAT WAS IN YOUR BILL IT ALSO I
TO DO WITH SORT OF DEALING WITH
THOSE WHO MAY BE MEDICALLY. AS
A MEDICALLY VULNERABLE BUT SO
HOW DO YOU SEE THE IN THE
PROCESS IS DOVE TAILING I NOTE
UC'S GOING THROUGH THEIR AFTER
ACTION REPORT RIGHT NOW.
THEY'LL MAKE THEIR OWN FINDINGS
DO THEY HAVE EXISTING FINE
AUTHORITY THEY CAN USE FOR
INSTANCE IF THEY FOUND THE LAST
ROUND OF THEM TO BE IMPRUDENT
OR DOES DO WE DO WE NEED THIS.
TO GIVE THEM THAT I THINK WE DO
NEED THIS AND I KNOW THE CEBU
CITY AND CENTER HERTZBERG ALSO
REYES IS HAS IT OPEN PROCEEDING
NOW- ON. SOME OF THE STANDARDS
FOR PS- YESES. AND I AND THE
BILL WILL TIE IN TO THAT IN
TERMS OF FINDING WHAT WHAT
WHETHER THE YES YES WAS. OF THE
BLACKOUT WAS REASONABLE OR
UNREASONABLE- ONE THING I WILL
SAY IS I AGREE WITH CENTER
HERTZBERG THERE A LOT OF MOVING
PARTS HERE AT CPAP PROCEEDING-
OUR OWN WORK HERE IN THE
SENATE- YES THE GOVERNOR HAS
NOT. YOU KNOW FULLY WAIT AND-
AND I KNOW. ALL OF THESE THINGS
WILL INTERPLAY IN THIS BILL. IF
IT'S KIDS MOVIE AND ITS
SUCCESSFUL- INTO YOU KNOW THE
END OF AUGUST. SO THIS IS GOING
TO PLAN TO A LOT. BUT HE WILL
WAY BROADLY OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEAR I WOULD EXPECT THEM TO
WEIGH IN EARLY IN THE PROCESS-
AND OUR OWN WORKING GROUP I'M
SURE WE'LL DO THAT. I WAS
ALREADY DOING FANTASTIC AT
WORK- AND THE CPC SO WE'LL
HAVE. PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITIES
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL AS
IT MOVES. MESHES AND
COMPLIMENTS EVERYTHING ELSE IS
HAPPENING THAT'S WHY I SAY IT
IS A- IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS
NOT IN A NEGATIVE WAY BUT IN A
WAY TO THE BROADER. PICTURE AND
VERY PLUGGED INTO THAT AND WILL
REMAIN. I APPRECIATE ALL THAT I
DON'T OVER PROMISE TO THE FOLKS
BACK HOME. WHO ARE WAITING THEY
PROBABLY WON'T GIVE THEM RELIEF
FOR. THE LAST INCIDENT IS WHAT
I'M HERE IN. I GUESS I'M ASKING
THE TECHNICAL MATTER. I DON'T
KNOW WHO CAN ANSWER THIS BUT
LIKE. CAN IF THE IF THE
UTILITIES EITHER P. JUNIOR ES
DE WERE IMPRUDENT. IN LAST
FALL'S YES PS IS CAN A FINE.
I'M UNDER EXISTING LAW. E. S.
I'M SEEING NOW YEAH YES SIR
INSTEAD OF HOW MUCH THAT FINE
IS THAT MORE WELL THIS IS A
WE'RE PUTTING SOME STRUCTURE-
STRUCTURE AROUND THAT AROUND
THE AND THE COMPENSATION AS
WELL THE CONVERSATION FRANKLY
THE MORE IMPORTANT A PIECE OF
IT MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
GET COMPENSATION AND JUST- I'VE
BEEN INFORMED THAT THERE
THERE'S AN OPEN. PROCEEDING
AGAINST P. JEANNIE RIGHT NOW.
OKAY THAT ON THAT ON THAT ISSUE
YEAH SO THAT'S THE ONLY THING I
JUST WANT CLARITY ON GOING
FORWARD FROM BOTH COMMITTEE AN
AUTHOR IS. I KNOW THAT. THERE'S
OF REASONABLENESS OR A FINDING
OF UNDER REASONABLENESS
REQUIREMENT NOW IN THE MEN'S
YOU TOOK. THAT PRUDENT SEE
DETERMINATIONS GOING TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE I
DON'T I DON'T WANT A SITUATION
WHERE THE I STILL THINK AND
EVERYONE CAN MONEY MORNING
QUARTERBACK IT BUT WE'LL SEE.
WHICH WAS CATASTROPHIC
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE REGION I
WORK FOR. WE HAD A BUNCH OF
TOWN HALLS BEFORE THAT WERE
EVERYONE IS YELLING AT S. C. E.
DON'T SHUT OFF THE POWER. AND
ALL OUR MAYORS AND I LOVE THE
MAYOR'S I WORK FOR AND ALL OF
YOU BACK HOME BUT THAT PUBLIC
PRESSURE I STILL THINK. AT MADE
HIM HESITATE. AND THAT
HESITATION. MAY VERY WELL
TRIGGERED WHAT BURN MY HOUSE
DOWN IN A LOT OF PEOPLE AND YOU
KNOW. IT'S SOME PEOPLE CAN
AFFORD TO RECOVER SOME PEOPLE
CAN'T THANKS SO I WOULD JUST
SAY I'LL BE VOTING FOR THE BILL
TODAY BUT. WORKING OUT THAT.
THAT PRUDENT SEE DETERMINATION
WILL BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THAT IN PRINT RIGHT NOW DO
YOU HAVE ANYTHING FOR US. WE'RE
WERE YOU WORKING THE LANGUAGE
IS NOT IMPRINT CARLTON- JUST
BECAUSE I HEARD THE TERM JUST
CAUSES NO FACTOR CAN YOU JUST
IF YOU HAVE AN ALBINO PARTING
IT'S ABOUT REASONABLENESS WHICH
WILL DETERMINE BY. BECAUSE
THEY'RE THE BINDING ALL OF THAT
NOW OKAY AND SO WE'RE SORT OF
PLAYING INTO THAT BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT AND WE'RE GIVING US
TO SEE IF YOU SEE AN INTERVIEW
YES THEY AN PUNISH UTILITIES
NOW. THE QUERY HOW THAT'S
WORKED IN THE PAST AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO STRUCTURE IT A LITTLE
MORE FOR THE COMMISSION SO IT'S
NOT JUST THE NEBULOUS. WE SORT
OF THING YOU DID SOMETHING
WRONG WE DON'T KNOW WE CAN FIND
YOU A LOT OR A LITTLE- THERE
HAS NOT BEEN ENOUGH
ACCOUNTABILITY- IN THE PAST FOR
THE UTILITIES PARTICULARLY FOR
P. JEANNIE- AND WE'RE TRYING TO
PUT SOME MORE STRUCTURE IN
PLACE. YEAH BUT THE WORKING
POOR WE WELCOME YOUR SPECIFIC
FEEDBACK TO I KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO DIRECT HAS BEEN A REALLY
GOING TO SENATOR RUBIO NOTHING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I JUST
WANNA OPENED UP I THINK IN THE
AUTHOR WE'VE SAT DOWN WE'VE
DISCUSSED ALL THE ISSUES THAT I
HALF WITH THE BILL AND DODD THE
ONE THING THAT I ALWAYS SAY IS
I APPRECIATE WHEN AUTHORS ARE
WANTING TO SIT DOWN AND TALK
ABOUT AS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AND MEDICAID AMEND HE'S ALREADY
DONE A GREAT JOB OF WORKING
WITH VANDALS ISSUES. BUT THE
ONE CONCERN THAT I SHARE IS
THAT TO FOR ME NUMBER ONE IS OP
PROTECTING LIVES AND THAT HAS A
TEN SEE THAT- MR STERN SPOKE
ABOUT IS REALLY LOOK AS ME
PAUSE. CAN NOW TELL WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DOES NOT BECOME CATASTROPHIC
AND SO WHEN WE HALF THE UTILITY
COMPANIES. THINKING TWICE AND
NOT ACTING BECAUSE YOU'RE SO
CONCERNED A BODY TO THE FEES OR
NOT HAVING ENOUGH TIME TO GO
OUT AND INSPECT THE LINES- I
KNOW ALL IN YOUR BILL IT.
DISCUSSES EVERY HOUR ON THE
HOUR PENALTIES. AND I WORRY
ABOUT TRYING TO DO IT WITHIN
THAT ONE HOUR SO THEY DON'T GO
INTO A SECOND OUR AND- AND SO
FOR ME SAY FEAR IS A BIG
CONCERN I'M SURE FOR EVERYONE
ELSE BUT I'M SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF- WE'VE BEEN DOING. I
THINK AN INCREDIBLE JOB OF
TRYING TO BE MINDFUL OF YOU
KNOW PEOPLE SHUT OFF IN TERMS
OF. YOU KNOW WHEN I HEARD RIGHT
NOW THIS STORY I'M SORRY THAT
TESTIMONY OF PATRICIA ROMERO.
YOU KNOW IT GIVES ME CONCERN AS
WELL THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT
CAN'T AFFORD TO GO BUY FOOD AND
DOWN SO I'M SURE SHE'S NOT THE
ONLY ONE THERE SO MANY CELL OF
COURSE THERE'S A BALANCE ON
BOTH SIDES WE WANT TO BE
RESPECTFUL RESPONSIBLE. TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO FOLKS LIKE
PATRICIA WHOSE EVERYTHING BUT
AT THE SAME TIME I FEEL THAT WE
ARE ALREADY ON OVER DRIVE
TRYING TO FIX THE PROBLEM. AS
EVIDENCED BY THE EIGHT HOUR I
THINK GOING TO HAVE TESTIMONY
THAT WE HAD. BACK IN NOVEMBER-
WE HAD A THREE HOUR AND A HALF
LAST WEEK. I HAPPEN TO BE CO
CHAIR OF THE WORKING GROUP THAT
IS WORKING REALLY DILIGENT NEED
TO COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS THAT
JOB. THINK WE'VE DONE RIGHT IN
TERMS IN TRYING TO BE INFORMED
AND READ INFORMATION AT OUR
FINGER TEST SO THAT WE CAN
SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND BRING ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE-
BUT I ALSO LIKE I SAID I'M VERY.
HOPEFUL BECAUSE YOU'VE DONE
SUCH A GREAT JOB OF COMING TO
MY OFFICE SITTING DOWN WITH ME
AND TALKING ABOUT THE SERIOUS
CONCERNS AND- FOR ME AS
STRIKING A BALANCE BETWEEN. THE
SAFETY OF PEOPLE THEIR LIVES
PROPERTY LOSS. BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT WE HOLD BAD ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE SWITCH THAT BALANCE
AND WE TRYING TO FIND AN- AND
WE'VE ALREADY DISCUSSED THAT
BECAUSE OF ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE WITH ME I WILL. GIVE YOU
THAT COURTESY BUILD BUT I.
REALLY WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT I
DON'T FEEL HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED
HERE TDAY AND- SO I JUST WANT
TO BE. VERY VOCAL ABOUT HOW I
FEEL ABOUT THIS BILL BACK.
AGAIN I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU AND I WILL CONTINUE
WORK WITH EVERYONE THAT'S COME
TO MY OFFICE TO ENSURE THAT WE
STRIKE THAT. MEANS THANK YOU.
YOU TURN THANKS OKAY. THANK WAS
IT THE AUTHOR WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS. THE OLD. I REALLY
DON'T BELIEVE THIS BILL IS
NEEDED YOUR FRANKLY WITH- THE
CBC OVERSIGHT I THINK IT IS
PREMATURE- CENTER HERTZBERG-
BROUGHT THAT POINT UP- I
BELIEVE IT GIVES PERVERSE
INCENTIVES THAT COULD HARM
PEOPLE AND AS A RUBIO JUST A
TALK ABOUT THAT AS WELL I THINK
ULTIMATELY AS CENTER BRADFORD
SAID IT ALSO IS GOING GREAT IT
COULD VERY WELL INCREASE RATES
FOR. EVERYBODY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER. I BELIEVE
WHAT I SAW ON THE POWERSHOT
OFFICE OF OCTOBER NIGHT. WAS A
BLATANT DISREGARD BY P. JEANNIE.
TO TRANSFER THEIR RISKS. FROM
RATE FROM THEMSELVES TO
RATEPAYERS IS RESULT OF THAT I
AM GOING TO VOTE TO SUPPORT-
MOVING THIS BILL ON THE LIKE
CENTER HERTZBERG I DO RESERVE
THE RIGHT I DO WANT TO SEE SOME
OF THESE THINGS CHANGED- IT
FIXED YOU'RE GOING FORWARD
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE I THINK IS REALLY-
IMPORTANT WELL HERE. AND WE'LL
GIVE A COURTESY VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU DID YOU WANT ME TO
I'M SORRY THANK YOU MISS TO IT
AT MISTER CHAIR I DIDN'T AND I
HAVE TO I AGREE WITH SENATOR
DODD'S COMMENTS AND JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING THAT I'VE HEARD
TODAY IT'S- KNOWING THIS WAS A
OF. A BLATANT DISREGARD AND-
THAT WE SAW IN IN OCTOBER AND
AN ACTION THAT. THAT SHOULD NOT
BE TOLERATED WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED IN THE FUTURE IN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE P. YOU SEE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY. TO DEVELOP
CERTAIN METRICS AROUND THE
FUTURE BLACKOUTS OR POWER SHUT
OFF THAT WERE RECEIVED AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE. THIS ISSUE
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED I DON'T
THINK LEGISLATING SOLUTIONS TO
THAT- IT IS THE BEST WAY. TO
HANDLE IT I AM I WILL SUPPORT
THE BILL BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
NECESSARY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE THERE MAY
BE THAT SWEET SPOT THAT WE
REGION AND CAN. DETERMINE AN
ACTION THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE DIGITAL AGE.
FOR TO DICTATE. HOW AND WHEN
AND WHEN. IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU FUTURE WE ENTERTAIN A
MOTION- WITH AMENDMENTS TO THE
FOR THE MANAGED TO BE TAKEN
APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION- DID YOU WANNA MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS- YES I JUST-
BRIEFLY- FOR SO THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I DO WANT TO STRESS
THAT THIS BILL. I'M ASSUMING IF
IT COMES OUT OF APPROPRIATIONS-
IT WILL BE ON THE FLOOR- WITHIN
A COUPLE WEEKS SO I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO. YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE WILL WELCOME AS
PROMPT FEEDBACK FROM AS
POSSIBLE BUT I DON'T YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT TWO WEEKS NOT A LOT
TIMES. YOUR RESULT EVERY ISSUE
WITH YOU THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR JUST TO SET THAT. AN
EXPECTATION- TO BE VERY CLEAR
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT BANNING
AND THE- THESE BAND BLACKOUTS
AS IS THE BEGINNING THEY HAVE A
ROLE TO PLAY AND WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO ELIMINATE THEM AND
THEY CAN SAVE. LIVES AND
PROPERTY IS ABOUT ESTABLISHING
A RUBIO SAID A BALANCE I AGREE
WE NEED A BALANCE AND RIGHT NOW
THERE IS NOT A BIG ONES WRITTEN
OUT UTILITIES. GINNY BUT I
TRUST P. JEANNIE. HOW ARE ARE
ARE IN ON THE SIDE A BROADER
AND BIGGER AND MORE FREQUENT
BLACKOUTS. TWO AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE IMPACTED UP ONE
OF THEM. AND SO IT'S A ALL
GIVING YOU TILL IT IS AN
INCENTIVE. TO USE PLAN
BLACKOUTS AS ACE AS A SCALPEL
AND NOT AS A SLEDGEHAMMER AND
RIGHT NOW WE ARE AT TIME SEEING
A SLEDGE HAMMER APPROACH. AND
THAT IS VERY VERY HOPEFUL TO
INDIVIDUAL- TO LOOK BOOK UNITY
IS THE ANSWER. AND TO ESTABLISH
THAT BALANCE. HILL AYE MCGUIRE
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
WILL HAVE A ROLE OF TRAPS AND
MEMBERS THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES. UP TAKE AS PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE POINT
TEN BE ARE WE THE COMMITTEE IS
REQUIRED TO HEAR SB THREE
EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR COUPLE
YET ALL AND TO TAKE TESTIMONY.
ON THIS BILL CIRCLE YOU'RE
WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE RECOMMENDATION IS GOING TO
BE TO HOLD THIS BILL IN
COMMITTEE AND SO I'M WHICH
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING THAT I'M
PRESENTING HERE TODAY- SB THREE
EIGHTY SIX IS A DISTRICT BILL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE ECONOMIC
FLEXIBILITY TO THE MODESTO
INTERLOCUTORS XIN DISTRICTS AND
THE RATE PAYERS. THAT HAVE BEEN
PRODUCING ZERO CARBON ENERGY
FOR OVER OVER THE YEARS YOU YOU
HEARD THIS BILL- IN AND IT
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE-
AND THAT AMENDMENT THAT WE MADE
WAS TO BE IN RESPONSE TO
OPPOSITION THE CONCERN THAT
THESE VARIEGATION DISTRICTS
COULD BACKSLIDE AND USE. THE
ENERGY- BE AMENDED THE BILL TO
ALLOW. ME TO REQUIRE THEM TO
INVEST. THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
OTHRWISE WOULD INVEST IN IN
SOLAR AND WIND ENERGY IN ENERGY
STORAGE- SO THAT- WE COULD.
HELP THEM TO MEET THEIR ENERGY
GOALS AND ALSO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE RATE PAYERS- BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW WHICH WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IS GENERATING ENERGY
WHICH THEY DON'T NEED ANY SELL
OFF AT A LOSS WHICH- IS THERE.
HERE'S TO PAY THE SCIENCE IS
CLEAR RENEWABLE ENERGY IS
GENERATED FROM SOLAR WIND AND
WATER WHEN THE R. PS WAS
CREATED SOLAR AND WIND NEEDED A
SUBSIDY TO COMPETE IN
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY MARKET
BECAUSE IT WAS SO EXPENSIVE.
TEN PLUS YEARS LATER CALIFORNIA.
HAVE BEEN PAYING EIGHT KERR
SAYS WE'RE ENERG IN ORDER TO
CURB OVER GENERATION AND
MAINTAIN A RELIABLE GRADE. LOW
INCOME AND POOR COMMUNITIES IN
SENATE-DISTRICT TWELVE HAVE
BEEN SUBSIDIZING SOLAR ENERGY
FOR WEALTHY POPULATED COASTAL
COMMUNITIES SINCE THE OUR PS
WAS ENACTED SB THREE EIGHTY SIX
IS AN EFORT TO MAKE MODEST
STEPS TOWARDS THAT INEQUALITY.
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE-
TERM IS CLIMATE GOALS LARGE
HYDRO AS A RECOGNIZED RENEWABLE
ENERGY SOURCE WASHINGTON STATE
WILL GET 21100% RENEWABLE
ENEGY BEFORE CALIFORNIA BY
KIND COUNTING HYDRO. CALIFORNIA
INSTEAD PLACE POLITICS IS WHAT
COUNTS AND WHEN THE GOAL TO
REACH SO THAT WALL STREET BACK
SOLAR ENERGY FIRMS CAN CONTINUE
CONVERTING AGRICULTURAL LAND
INTO SOLAR FARMS. OR SO THAT
MASSIVE PART OF THE NEVADA
DESERT CAN BE CONVERTED TO
SOLAR FORMS WITH NEW
TRANSMISSION LINES IN
INFRASTRUCTURE CARING THAT
RENEWABLE ENERGY HUNDREDS OF
MILES BACK THROUGH NATURAL
LANDS RIGHT BACK TO LOS
ANGELES. SB THREE EIGHTY SIX
WAS MADE INTO A STATEWIDE
LIGHTNING ROD LAST YEAR- AS I
SAID THIS COMMITTEE PASSED IT
OUT AND IT WAS SET TO BE HEARD
ON THE FLOOR. AND FORMER
LEADERS OF THIS SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA USE THE SEAL OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO PUSH MEMBERS
INTO CHANGING THEIR VOTE. AS I
SAID AFTER IT PASSED FROM THIS
COMMITTEE. SB THREE EIGHTY SIX
IS NOT SET NEW PRESIDENT. OTHER
PO USE CURRENTLY COUNT THEIR
HYDRO ENERGY TO SATISFY
RENEWABLE ENERGY PROCUREMENT
REQUIREMENTS. THE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT THOSE PO USE GET TO COUNT
OVER 50% OF THEIR HYDRO ENERGY
AND DON'T YOU TO PROCURE EXCEPT
RENEWABLES. BECAUSE SO MUCH OF
THEIR ENERGY COMES FROM GROW.
NOW THERE IS A TYPICAL
GOVERNMENT CREATED OXYMORON.
THE PROBLEM IS IT TURLOCK IN
MODESTO DO NOT GET ENOUGH OF
THEIR ENERGY FROM DON PEDRO DAM
OR THEY WOULD QUALIFY FOR IN
OUR P. S. EXEMPTION IN OTHER
WORDS SAN FRANCISCO HAS THE
EXEMPTION BUT NOT- RURAL
CALIFORNIA. SB THREE EIGHTY
SIXES ABOUT EQUITY UNDER THE
OUR PS AND NOT PLAYING POLITICS
WITH SCIENCE IN ORDER TO
MANIPULATE POLITICAL IN ENERGY
MARKETS. WHEN FEDERAL DOLLY
COMMITTEE SUBSIDIZE ENERGY FOR
OTHERS. THIS IS A VERY OF A
REGRESSIVE TAX ON OUR POOREST
COMMUNITIES IN THE FORM OF HIGH
ENERGY COSTS. AS WE DID IN THE
ANALYSIS HE COSTS ARE NOT IN
THIS VALLEY WHERE IT IS HOT IN
THE SUMMER AND COLD IN THE
WINTER AND TIERED RATE SYSTEM.
POOR THE MOST. JEAN SECURITY IS
HIGHEST. IN THE CENTRAL IN
IMPERIAL VALLEY'S. INNER
WEALTHIEST COASTAL AREAS WHERE
TEMPERATURES ARE MORE MODERATE.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WILL HAVE
THESE POOR COMMUNITY
SUBSIDIZING SOLAR AND WIND FOR
ANOTHER TWENTY YEARS IGNORING
GOOD SCIENCE THE COUNT WATER
SOLAR AND WIND ACT EQUITABLY.
REGARDING THE COST LIMITATION%
COMPLIANCE OPTION DON PEDRO IS
AN ASSET THAT IS OWNED BY THE
DISTRICTS PURSUING ACOSTA
LIMITATION OP OPTION WHICH IS
IN THE- IN THE ANALYSIS WOULD
NEGATIVELY AFFECT THE DISTRICTS
FINANCING STANDING. THE
DISTRICT MIGHT MUST ENSURE
CONTINUED CAPITAL AXIS AT
REASONABLE COST IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN THE DAM AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ASSETS THE
DISTRICTS CREDIT PROFILE IS
ALREADY LIMITED BY THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES THAT EXCEED
STATE AND NATIONAL AVERAGES AND
THE DEPRESSD ECONOMIC PROFILE
OF THEIR SERVICE TERRITORY. THE
COST LIMITATION OPTION WOULD
ESSENTIALLY INDICATE TO THE
MARKET THAT THE DISTRICTS COULD
NOT MEET THEIR FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS. WOULD LEAD TO A
DETERIORATION OF THE FINANCIAL
PROFILE AND WILL BE DISASTROUS
FOR THEM. ACCORDING TO THE
METHODOLOGY USED BY MOODY'S
CREDIT RATING COMPANY FOR ITS
U. S. PUBLIC POWER ELECTRIC
UTILITIES WITH GENERATION
OWNERSHIP EXPOSURE PUBLIC POWER
ELECTRIC UTILITIES THAT OWN
GENERATION ASSETS HAVE MORE
BUSINESS COMPLEXITY AND
FUNDAMENTAL CREDIT RISKS THAN
THOSE WHO DO NOT OWN GENERATION
ASSETS WHICH IS TRUE WITH OTHER
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS. THESE
RISKS INCLUDE EXPOSURE TO
COMMODITY MARKETS ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATION AND CAPITAL
REQUIREMENTS TO MAINTAIN
REFURBISH A REPLACE GENERATION
ASSETS. MOODY'S METHODOLOGY
CONSIDERS A NUMBER OF FACTORS
FOR THE RATINGS INCLUDING THE
ABILITY TO HAVE PREDICTABLE AND
TIME THE RATE SETTING THE
STRENGTH OF THE CUSTOMER BASE
SERVE THEIR ECONOMY. GENERATION
AND POWER PROCUREMENT RISK
EXPOSURE AND ABILITY TO
MAINTAIN DEBT SERVICE PAYMENTS.
COST CONTAINMENT IS DETRIMENTAL
TO DISTRICTS THAT STILL HAVE TO
BEAT THE 1100% ZERO INNER
CARBON ENERGY MANDATE BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE IN OTHER WORDS. THAT
NEED TO MARKET THAT NEED. GO TO
THE MARKET TO MAKE LOOK. AS I
SAID IN MY INTRODUCTION THIS IS
A DISTRICT BELL IT DEALS WITH
EQUITY. GOOD SCIENCE AND ALLOWS
FLEXIBILITY TO MEET THE MEET
THE GOOD CLIMATE GOALS THAT WE
ALL WANT TO MEET. STORAGE IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO INVEST IN IN
IF I MIGHT SAY- PART OF WHAT
WHAT HAS BECOME CLEAR TO ME IN
THIS WHOLE ENERGY SECTOR AS WE
LOOK AT MAKING NVESTMENTS IN
THE RP A SYSTEM MAKING
INVESTMENTS. IN IN STORAGE AND
HOW THIS ALL PLAYS OUT WITH
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
HIGHER THE RISK OF FIRES. IS
THAT WE HAVE DONE A REALLY POOR
JOB OF GUARANTEEING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE OUR OUR
ELECTRICAL GET WORKING AND
RUNNING. AND WHAT PEOPLE ARE
TURNING TO IS OUR DIRTY
GENERATORS WHO ARE WHO ARE
PROLIFERATING ALL OVER THE
STATE AS A WAY TO HAVE ENERGY
SECURITY AND THOSE GENERATORS
ARE. BY WITH ENERGY SOURCES
THAT ARE NOT CONSISTENT WITH A
CLEAN AREA ERROR ERROR GOALS
AND SO WE'RE CREATING THIS THIS.
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT WHERE WHAT
PEOPLE ARE DOING IS THEY'RE
MOVING TO SOMETHING THAT IS
GOING TO BE CONTRARY TO OUR TO
OUR GOALS IN THE STATE SO- WITH
THAT I WOULD SAY I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR VOTE THE LAST TIME I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS GOING TO BE
HELD A COMMITTEE- I MEDICARE.
AND RECENT PRESENTING TODAY ARM
IS I'M AT OUR RATE PAYER.
PAYERS HOW CAN WE INSURE THAT
WE HAVE THE ELECTRICAL- AG
AGREED WORKING AT AND HOW CAN
WE INVEST IN THE KINDS OF
THINGS HOW CAN WE TAKE THE
LIMITED DOLLARS. THAT ARE
TAXPAYERS ARE RATE PAYERS ARE
PAYING AND INVEST THEM IN IT IN
A SYSTEM THAT'S GOING TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE- AT A RELIABLE
SOURCE OF ENERGY IN YEARS TO
COME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PERCENT.
ENGINER ANY QUESTION I WANT ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE BECOME FOR.
MORNING MIKHAIL SCARLET HERE
THE- WITH THE GOLF WITH YOU ON
BEHALF OF MISTER NATION
DISTRICT AND FOR THE REASONS
THAT OUR STATE OR IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I REMEMBER THE OF
THE TRUCKER ASIAN DISTRICT HERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. PATRICK
THE CALIFORNIA SPEED TILDES
CESSATION ALSO IN SUPPORT. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FOR. WHAT TO A TABLE AND
ON. THE REST WILL I SHOULD FORM
A LINE AT THE MIKE FOR. THANK
YOU MATT FRIEDMAN WITH THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK- WE ARE
HERE TO OPPOSE SB THREE EIGHTY
SIX WE UNDERSTAND THE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES FACED
BY CUSTOMERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND AS THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS WE'VE BEEN A LEADER IN
FIGHTING FOR LOWER RATES AND
FOR PROTECTING LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS BUT WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THREE EIGHTY SIX HELPS
LEASE LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS AND
IT WOULD BE IN OUR VIEW HIGHLY
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO CHEAT IN A
VARIETY OF STATE GOALS. WE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN WORKING.
WITH THE COMMITTEE. FOR TURNING
METHODS FOR INSURING
AFFORDABILITY THAT DID NOT
INVOLVE THE ROLLBACK OF THE
STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY AND
CLIMATE POLICIES. IN ARGUE
THERE IS NO SPECIFIC
JUSTIFICATION FOR PROVIDING ON
THE EXAM AND IN THIS BILL KLAY
TO ERIC DISTRICTS. WHO RECEIVE
AVERAGE OF ABOUT AN HOUR SENATE
RETAILS. FROM DON DROVE LIKE TO
OBJECT THERE MAY THERE YOU TO
IN THIS THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
LARGE HYDRO SOURCES. IN THEIR
PORTFOLIOS. IN ARGUE THERE IS
NO JUST. I THINK YOU NEED TO
THE BRIGADE STRIKES THAT WILL
BUY TO ALL THE OTHER UTILITIES.
IF THAT SAME TREATMENT WERE
PROVIDED ALL THE OTHER
UTILITIES IT WOULD HAVE
DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES. FOR
THE STATE'S PROGRAMS I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT UNIQUELY
EXCLUDE LARGE HYDRO POWER FROM
THE ACHIEVEMENT OF ITS
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
GOALS- MOST STATES EXCLUDE
LARGE HYDRO FROM THERE ARE PS
PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA THOUGH LIKE
MOST OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
ADOPTED THE ZERO CARBON TARGETS
INCLUDES LARGE HYDRO ELECTRIC.
AS THE TO BRIDGE THE TREATMENT
OF THE HUNT PERCENT EUROCHART A
LOT SECTOR. TOWARDS EACH MINUTE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE AND GOALS
ALSO COUNTED AS A CARBON
RESOURCE FOR PURPOSES OF THE
POWER CONTENT LET. INTERVIEWED
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE AS NOTED IN
THE IN OUR ANY PUBLICLY OWNED
UTILITY CAN ADOPT COST
CONTAINMENT MECHANISM TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO DETERMINE
WHAT TYPES OF COSTS THEY ARE
WILLING T INCUR TO MEET THE
STATE'S RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARDS. THESE MECHANISMS
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED BY A NUMBER
OF PUBLIC. OR THEIR ABILITY TO
FINANCE NEW RESOURCES WE'VE
SEEN NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
ADOPTION OF THESE LIMITS WHICH
ARE PERMITTED UNDER STATE LAW
HAVE ANY NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON
THE ABILITY OF THESE UTILITIES
TO ATTRACT AND RETAIN IN
FINANCING- IN ADDITION. TO THE
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH NEW PRINCE
IS IRRIGATION DISTRICTS BUYS.
GEORGE WHICH THESE UTILITIES
HAVE FOUND IN THEIR INTERPRETED
RESOURCES PLANS ARE NOT COST
EFFECTIVE THEREFORE IT APPEARS
THIS BILL WOULD IMPOSE NEW CAR
NEW COSTS ON THE IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS. ARE RELATIVE TO WHAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED UNDER STATE
LAW. IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT. BOTH OF THESE IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
PROCUREMENT OF OUR PS ELIGIBLE
RESOURCES UNDER CURRENT LAW AS
NECESSARY TO MEET THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
TARGETS ESTABLISHED BY THE
STATE AS PART OF THEIR
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANS. IT
IS NOT CLEAR HOW THESE
UTILITIES METER GHG REDUCTION
TARGETSUNDER STATE LAW WITHOUT
THESE ARE PS ELIGIBLE
RESOURCES. TO FINALLY IN OUR
VIEW THIS BILL IS NOT REALLY A
DISTRICT BILL AT SCORE ALTHOUGH
WE RECOGNIZE THAT IT DOES
AFFECT THE PARTICULAR UTILITIES
WE THINK IT TO WIPE RANGING
PACKS OF THE STATE. PROGRAM AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY IS SIMPLY NOT
NEXT TO ADDRESS CONCERNS IS TO
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS AND WE
THINK THE COMMITTEE SHOULD.
ALTER APPROACH IN THE FUTURE.
IT WOULDN'T CATHERINE PHILLIPS
WITH SIERRA CUB CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OUR- MILLION
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS AROUND
THE STATE INCLUDING IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY- THEY ARE PS IS
BEEN ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TOOLS FOR REDUCING LOCAL HEALTH
THREATENING. AIR POLLUTION AND
CLIMATE POLLUTION. AND AS SAID
EARLIER- THE OUR PS IS A
WORKING. THIS BILL WOULD
UNDERCUT THAT SUCCESS. THIS IS
MORE THAN A DISTRICT BILL.
TAKING AN ACTION LIKE THIS BILL
PROPOSES AND WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCES WOULD BEFORE
EXPANDING OF BROADLY A HYDRO
INTO THE OUR PS. OF WOULD SEND
A SIGNAL THAT CALIFORNIA'S
BACKING AWAY FROM COMMITMENT TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY. AND IT'S
COMMIT TO CUTTING CLIMATE
POLLUTION. SO ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBERS I URGE YOU TO REJECT
THIS BILL AND- YOU KNOW IT WAS
A BAD BILL LAST YEAR IT'S A BAD
BILL THIS YEAR I HOPE IT
DOESN'T COME UP NEXT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS COME
MARTINEZ WELL ON BEHALF OF
EARTH JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. YOUR NUMBER STILL ANY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEGE AND ANY
OF A LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. IT WILL BE AIRED WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION ALONG WITH SEVEN OR
EIGHT OTHER HEALTH AND MEDICAL
ORGANIZATIONS ALSO STATING
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MELISSA C<c.cyan> BROUGHT</c>
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AARON
RODRIGUEZ WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
pJEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THE TRUCK NUMBER
HALF AMERICAN WHEN ENERGY
ASSOCIATION ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND IN BOTH SOLAR
OPPOSITION. RONALD STORK ON
BEHALF OF FRIENDS OF THE RIVER
IN THE CALIFORNIA HIGH TO POWER
REFORM COALITION IN OPPOSITION.
THE CARD WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING- JIM
LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA AND
OPPOSITION I'M ALSO HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
INTERFACE POWER AND LIGHT-
LUCERNE OFFICE OF PUBLIC POLICY
OF CALIFORNIA COWORKERS CARE
WITNESS AND THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN. ALL IN
OPPOSITION. WONDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
PART OF THE PREVIOUS FAITH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN
OPPOSITION. SALINAS EARLY SHAUN
BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY IN OPPOSITION. TINA
GAILLARD FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO THREE FIFTY SOUTH
BAY LA AND FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
BERMAN CALIFORNIA DAN JACOBSON
OPPOSITION THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMISSIONER DOT
I YEAH I WAS ONE THAT- VOTED ON
THIS LAST TIME SENATOR AND I'VE-
YOU HAVE GOT A LOT OF- BALLS
AND- LEARNED A LOT ABOUT THIS
ISSUE THAT I DID NOT KNOW-
BEFORE WHAT I VOTED ON IT. I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK TWO
QUESTIONS- THAT THE PERMIT. ONE
OF THE POLICIES THAT WE HAVE
IS- THE LAST 40% YOU CAN USE
HYDRO AS PART OF YOUR- ACCOUNT
SO I GUESS WHAT I'M WONDERING
IS YOU KNOW WHY IS IT WHY ISN'T
THAT GOOD ENOUGH WHAT'S THE
ECONOMIC. IMPACT OF WITHIN THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE ALREADY THE
POLICIES WE HAVE A PLACE TODAY
AND- YOUR ACHIEVING THAT 60%
AND THEN USE IT THE YOU UTILIZE
THE LAST 40% AS- PART OF A-
100% GOAL. REALLY GOOD QUESTION
THAT THE IT WHO HAS TO DO WITH
WHEN YOU GET TO COUNT HYDRO-
FOR THE USERS THAT ARE. I WOULD
SAY. AND THIS IS PART OF THE
INEQUITY IN THE SYSTEM IS THAT
IF YOUR IF YOUR USE OF HYDRO IS
SMALL ENOUGH THEN YOU GET TO
COUNT IT NOW- AND- AND AS I
SAID IS THIS PERVERSE THIS
PERVERSE SYSTEM IS. THE DON
PEDRO JENNA DAM HAS BEEN THERE
FOR ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS IT'S
NINETY THREE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT- AND- AND IT'S BEEN GREEN
FOR BEGINNING JUST AND- THAT
THE- POINT AT WHICH YOU'VE GOT
TO CAPITA IT. NOW DOESN'T TO
YOUR BET. ARE YOU AFTER MARK
YEAH I DID HIT TARGET TWENTY
TWENTY HAVE TO HIT TARGETS FOR
TWENTY THIRTY AND THEN AT THE
END YOU CAN USE THAT FOR TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. AND SO THAT THEY
THEIR THESE PARTICULAR
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS HAVE HAD
MAJOR INVESTMENTS. IN SOLAR AND
WIND ENERGY DESPITE THE FACT
THAT. DAM GENERATED OF ENERGY-
ALMOST BY ITSELF DEPENDING ON
THE YEAR FOR THE RATE PAYERS
AND SO THEY END UP WITH EXCESS
ENERGY AND HAVE TO SELL IT
SOMETIMES IN CALIFORNIA. AND
SOMETIMES OUT OF STATE AND
BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD TO PAY A
PREMIUM FOR THAT DEVELOPMENT OF
THEIR SOLAR IN THEIR WIND
ENERGY. FACILITIES THEY HAVE TO
SELL IT AT A LOSS AGAIN THE
RATE PAYERS PAY THE COST OF
THAT AND SO THAT THAT. IT DID
ACT THAT'S THE ANSWER TO IT IS
A GET TO USE IT AT THE VERY END
BUT YOU CAN'T USE IT NOW THEY
HAVE TO CONTINUE MAKING AND
COMMENCE. BUT THE YOU MADE IN
YOUR OPENING TESTIMONY WAS
ABOUT THE- FINANCIAL VIABILITY
FOR YOUR RATE THE RATE PAYERS
OF PAY MORE. IT'S ALSO MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THERE'S A
HARDSHIP EXEMPTION UNDER THE.
THE CODE AT THIS POINT TIME
THAT. THE GOOD THERE COULD BE
SOMETHING THIS FILE LIKE I
GUESS WHERE I'M GOING HERE IS
YEAH I WAS WILLING TO VOTE FOR
THAT FRANKLY I THINK- YOU'VE
BEEN BILL IF I BRING THIS UP I
OBJECT TO THAT I THINK THAT.
YOU KNOW IT'S COURAGE SOMETIME
TO BRING UP POLICY THE IS. THAT
MIGHT NOT MAKE SENSE TO AN
INDIVIDUAL MATE- OR THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND WE'VE SEEN THE OPPOSITION
HERE TODAY. I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND THE OVERALL. INTERESTS THAT
WE HAVE YOUR ABOUT PRECEDENCE.
THAT ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN OUR
GREEN ENERGY PROCUREMENTS.
FLIGHT CONGRATULATE YOU FOR- IF
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING UP A
TOUGH ONE BUT I THINK THAT.
MORE FROM MY STANDPOINT-
BECAUSE OF THOSE PRESS THIS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE
MORE CONVERSATION I'M- WILLING
HAVE THAT WITH YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT. I DO NOT HAVE
ARTICULATED. IT CLEARLY BUT I'M
ASKING. THE VOTE BE HELD ON THE
BILL IN OTHER WORDS I'M NOT
ASKING THAT IT GO OUT AND SO- I
THINK. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I'D LIKE A IN IT LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION I GUESS
A BIG PART OF THE PASSION I
HAVE FOR THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
IS THAT. ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT
ALL IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THERE ARE INDEED TENDING
CONSEQUENCES- AND I FEEL PART
OF OUR OBLIGATION IS TO. SAY
LOOK HERE'S THE SCIENCE. ARE
YOU THAT THE AIR IS GONNA GET
DIRTY OR BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
COUNT HYDRO NOT NOW THAT'S
DISINGENUOUS TO ME. IF YOU'RE
SAYING WE MAY REVERT TO DIRTY
YOUR SOURCES OF ENERGY I GET IT
AND THAT'S THE REASON THAT WE
LOOKED AT. UP PUTTING A
LIMITATION F THE WHICH YOU
CAN'T BACKSLIDE NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO. LET'S LOOK AT
STORAGE BECAUSE THERE'S
DEFINITELY A NEED FOR STORAGE
AND- AND THAT'S- WHAT THE COST
MORE YES BUT IT SOLVES ANOTHER
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WHICH IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ULTIMATELY. NEED STORAGE WHEN
THE WIND DOESN'T BLOW IN THE
SUN DOESN'T SHINE. AND IF IT'S
A DROUGHT THEN WE'RE GONNA NEED
STORAGE AND SO THAT'S THE
REASON WE MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION BUT BUT AT THIS POINT
TO IT. I GUESS I JUST FELT LIKE
ON BEHALF OF MY CONSTITUENTS IT
HAD TO BE HEARD. AND I AM
ASKING THE COMMITTEE VOTE TO
HOLD THE BILL THANK YOU. NEED
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FOR TAKES
GREAT COURAGE BUT AS YOU SHOULD
CLEARLY STATED THIS IS ABOUT
BEING HONEST AND GENUINE AND
TRANSPARENT TO NOT ONLY YOUR
DISTRICT BUT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WAS A CHEER OF
UTILITY COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY
WHEN OUR PS BILLS ARE MOVING
FOR IT WAS A MAJOR FIGHT TO
MAKE SURE HYDRO WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THAT BECAUSE IT
ALLOWED US TO BUILD A LOT OF
AND SOLAR THAT TRULY WAS NEEDED
BUT AT THE SAME TIME. WE'RE
SHEDDING MORE POWER HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
MORE TO NEVADA THERE WERE USING
DURING THE COURSE OF THE DAY
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO BE HONEST
I'M GOING TO CAN YOU TALK ABOUT
A DRUG- FOR THE LAST TEN YEARS
THAT'S THE REASON A DARKER VIEW
IS GROWING BECAUSE WE'RE
BUILDING. MORE OPEN AND SOLAR
THAT NOT DISPATCH BILL. I WON
THE MOST RELIABLE ENERGY
SOURCES WE HAVE. WE SAW PROOF
OF IT FROM BC IN. BRITISH
COLUMBIA- WASHINGTON DC WENT TO
CANADA IT WORKS IN ALL THOSE
COUNTRIES. THEY'RE NOT HAVING
GROWING POLLUTION BECAUSE OF
USING HIGH HYDRO WHICH WAS ONE
OF THE CLEANEST SOURCES AROUND.
BUT WE BECOME HYPOCRITES AS
LEGISLATORS WHEN WE CONTINUE TO
PICK WINNERS AND LOSERS THIS
HOUSE VALUE WE SHOULD BE. ADDED
TO OUR PORTFOLIO WHICH SHOULD
BE COUNTY TOWARD- OUR OUR PS A
REQUIREMENT JUST LIKE ROOFTOP
SOLAR SHOULD BE COUNTED BUT IF
WE COUNTED THAT. WOULD WELL BE
CAST 60% WOULD BE WELL ON OUR
WAY TO. RENO WHEN PROJECT BUT
WE DON'T DO THAT BECAUSE WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO BUILD MORE
MORE. RESOURCES THAT ARE NOT
NEEDED SO I RESPECT THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE NOT CALL BEFORE
VOTE BUT IF YOU ARE. I WOULD BE
I VOTE FOR THE DAY SO. MEASURE
WHICH ONE. EXPECT YOUR BOAT TO
HOLD IT IN BILLING. WE WILL
BUILD A COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. FOR YOUR HELP.
CAPTION YES WITH NO OBJECTIONS
WERE HOLDEN COMMITTEE. JERRY
YOU HAVE SB SEVEN OH TWO WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY BEGIN I DO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES LET ME BEGIN BY
THANKING THIS COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS MEASURE
AND EX AND I ACCEPT THE A
PROPOSED TO MEN. OUTLINED IN
THE ANALYSIS. TO TAKE IN THE
MA'AM IT'S AN APPROPRIATE.
MEASURE BUT TO MAKE A MINOR
CHANGE TO THE RBS STATUES LONG
TERM CONTRACTING PROVISION THE
GOES INTO EFFECT NEXT JANUARY
UNDER EXISTING LAW CUSTOMERS
THAT CHOOSE TO DIRECTLY
PRECURSOR RENEWABLE SORT
RESOURCES SUCH AS STANFORD
UNIVERSITY MAY DO SO AND HAVE
THEIR OUR PS CREDITS COUNT FOR
THEIR RETAIL SALES SELLER
HOWEVER GETTING JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT ELIGIBILITY IS
REVOKED. BECAUSE STATE INFERRED
NOT THEIR TAIL SELLERS HOLDING
OFF TO THE LONG TERM CONTRACT
THIS WAS NOT THE INTENT OF THE
OUR PS AS A COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THE LONG TERM
CONTRACTING PROVISION IN THE RP
AS WAS INTENDED ENSURE MARKET
CERTAINTY RENEWAL ELEMENT
STANFORD IS TAKING AN
AGGRESSIVE APPROACH TO READ SHE
IN. THE HOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
SPEECH HELLO TO ENSURE. LONG
RENEW. CAN YOU DO IT WITH THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
JOSEPH STAGGER STANFORD
UNIVERSITY WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS AND-
SUPPORT THE BILL WE HAVE A MOVE
TO ELECT FIRE CAMPUS WHERE 80%
THROUGH THE PHYSICAL
TRANSFORMATION WERE BUILDINGS
AND TRANSPORTATION BUILT
TRICITY ELECTRICITY WAS A
COMPANION WE NEED CLEAN ELECT
CITY DE CARBONIZED WE'VE MOVED
WITH ONE LARGE OR PLAN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SIGNED A CONTRACT FOR
ANOTHER TO BE BUILT IN TWO
YEARS MORE THAT WE ARE. TO BE A
HOAX CARBON BE WE NEED THIS
LIKE PATIENT PASS THAT THESE
WILL COUNTY TO OUR PS OTHERWISE
OUR ENERGY SERVICE PROVIDER
WOULD HAVE TO PROCURE REDUNDANT
RENEWABLES FOR US AND EXCEED.
1100% SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANK YOU MATT
FRIEDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ON AS AS
POINTED OUT BY SENATOR HILL
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES AT LEAST
65% OF EACH LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES. ARE PS PROCUREMENT TO
BE SOURCED UNDER LONG TERM
CONTRACTS STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED THIS REQUIREMENT IN SB
THREE FIFTY AND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS IS TO PROMOTE MARKET
STABILITY. AND PLACE A PRIMARY
EMPHASIS ON CONTRACTING
ACTIVITIES THAT WILL DRIVETHE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW RENEWABLE
RESOURCES. BUT LONG TERM
CONTRACTS MUST BE EXECUTED BY
THE LOAD SERVING ENTITY IN
ORDER TO COUNT THIS IS A
CRITICAL FEATURE OF THE PROGRAM.
WE'VE NOTED IN OUR- VIEW OF THE
OUR PS PROGRAM THAT IN
PARTICULAR DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDERS ARE FACING CHALLENGES
IN MEETING BOTH THERE ARE P.
ASK AND THEIR LONG TERM
CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS. A
RECENT YOU SEE REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE NOTES THE DIRECT
ACCESS SUPPLIERS ARE CURRENTLY
SHORT OF MEETING THEIR 33%
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS FOR
TWENTY TWENTY. THE PC HAS ALSO
EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ABILITY OF DIRECT ACCESS
PROVIDERS. MEET THE LONG TERM
CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS- IN
RECENT REPORTS IN DECISIONS
THAT THEY'VE ISSUED. NOW WE
KNOW THAT SOME DIRECT ACCESS
CUSTOMERS DO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ENTER IN THE LONG TERM. IT'S
THEMSELVES FOR IN OUR PS
RESOURCE. YOUR OF AN- INSTANT
DISABLED. AND COST. MAKING
DIRECT LONG TERM WHOLESALE
COMMITMENTS TO PURCHASE THE
OUTPUT OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
DIRECTLY FROM NEWLY CONSTRUCTED
LARGE SCALE FACILITIES. AND IN
MANY CASES THESE CUSTOMER
COMMITMENTS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL TO FINANCING AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROJECTS
THESE ARE PRIMARILY
INSTITUTIONAL CUSTOMERS APPLE
GOOGLE FACEBOOK STANFORD. THE
UC SYSTEM I'M AND THERE'S SOME
CAPACITY FOR ADDITIONAL LARGE
CUSTOMERS TO MAKE THESE NEW
LONG TERM COMMITMENTS BUT UNDER
CURRENT LAW THEY CAN'T BE
COUNTED TOWARDS THE OUR PS
REQUIREMENTS. OF THE LOAD
SERVING AND EIGHTY SERVING THAT
CUSTOMER BECAUSE THAT LOW
SERVING AND HE'S NOT THE
COUNTERPARTY. IN OUR VIEW
ALLOWING CUSTOMER CONTRACT TO
COUNT TOWARDS THE LONG TERM
CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS MAKES
SENSE AS LONG AS THEY'RE
APPROPRIATE RESTRICTIONS TO
PREVENT ABUSE. SB SEVEN OH TWO
INCLUDES THE APPROPRIATE
PROVISIONS WE THINK IT MAKES
SENSE WE UNDERSTAND THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WOULD
RESTRICT THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL
WILL. LIKELY TO THE DEAL THAT
WERE EXECUTED BY STANFORD WE
THINK THAT THE LEGEND SHOULD.
WOULDN'T IT ALL. RACKS THE
PROPOSED CHANGES WITH A LOT
BRING COURAGE THESE CUSTOMERS
TO ENTER INTO LONG TERM
CONTRACTS FOR NEW RESOURCES
WITHOUT CREATING LOOPHOLES THAT
UNDERMINE THE ABILITY OF THE
STATE TO ACHIEVE ITS GOALS AND
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PRINCIPLE AT STAKE HERE WHAT
ESTABLISH THE CORRECT
INCENTIVES TO SPUR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF INCREMENTAL
RESOURCES IN THE COMING YEARS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE
QUICKNESS THANK YOU MELISSA
CORTEZ ROTH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE ARE CAUGHT WITHOUT OF
TURN WE'D LIKE TO SEE CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS ALL WHILE SHE THE
NARROWING SPELL IT LIKE IT CAN
DISCUSSIONS BEYOND JUST A STAND
FOR CONTRACT THANK YOU A TO
ADDRESS. HERE I GUESS FOR THE
UNION A SCIENTIST IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LEAVE ERAS ON BEHALF
OF THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
COMMITTEE CASSANDER GOFF WITH
CALPINE CAL PAINS IN A UNIQUE
POSITION BOTH AS AN INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PROVIDER WE HAVE OUR
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES I ALWAYS
TALK TO YOU ABOUT- BUT WE'RE
ALSO AND ENERGY SERVICE
PROVIDER OR FORTUNATE TO HAVE
STANFORD THE OUR CUSTOMER- AND
WE DO BACK OFFICE WORK FOR CCA
SO WORK FOR UNIQUE IN THAT
AREA. WE SUPPORT THE BILL AS
REGIONALLY INTRODUCED NOT ONLY
FOR OUR CUSTOMERS- BUT ALSO
WEARING A RENEWABLE ENERGY HAT.
IT'S NO THAT NO NEWS TO ANY OF
YOU THAT THE THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN NO LARGE SCALE R. F. THOSE
FOR RENEWABLE RESOURCES AND SO
WE THINK INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF BUYERS IS BETTER AND ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH MR FRIEDMAN'S-
COMMENTS SO WE WOULD HOPE THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION
SO THAT IT NOT ONLY BENEFITS-
STANFORD BUT OTHER CUSTOMERS
AND ALSO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO POINT TO POINT OUT THAT IS I
EXTEND THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED IF STATE TWENTY. S. OR
CITED TO GO BACK TO THE
INCUMBENT UTILITY THE CCA BACK
TRY GO WITH THEM SO ALL LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES WHO HAVE TO
MEET THE 65% STANDARD. GET THE
BENEFIT OF THE CONTRACT THAT
THAT STANFORD OR ANY OTHER AND
USE CUSTOMER BRINGS WITH THEM
AND WE'VE ALL READ THE
HEADLINES THE GOOGLE'S THE
WALMARTS THE JOHNSON AND
JOHNSON THEY'RE ALL ENTERING
INTO THESE CONTRACTS. AND WE
WANT TO KEEP THOSE INCENTIVES
GOING BECAUSE MORE BUYERS ARE
GOOD SO THANK YOU WHEN WE LOOK
FOR TO KICKING IN CONVERSATION
RICHARD. THE QUICKNESS THEIR
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GOING
TO BE HAVE THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT CENTERS
BACK. THANK YOU. WILL ABRAMS
PARTY TO THE CPC PROCEEDINGS IN
VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS AND
I THINK IT'S A VERY MEASURED
APPROACH THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TO CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DELIC
TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF OF
ALBERT'S THE SAFE WAY WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL.
BUT WE ACCEPT YOUR OFFER TO
INCLUDE OTHER BUSINESSES WITH
THESE CONTRACTS INTO THIS
PROCESS INTO THIS BILL. AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD SO I JUST WANTED
TO PUBLICLY STATE OUR INTENTION
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
OTHERS. TO INCLUDE SAFE WAY WHO
HAS THESE TYPE OF CONTRACTS AS
WELL INDEED THIS BILL AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IN ADDITION WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THREE NINE BRING IT TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS WITH COMMITTEE. I'M
SORRY I ANY OPPOSITION THANK
YOU MISTER GO ANY OPPOSITION
BUT USING OUR OPPOSITE TO HEAL
BILL RIGHT. ALL RIGHTS BEING NO
OPPOSITION- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR DODD. BUT WE HAVE A
WHAT IS OUR. YOU PASS YOUR
TESTS TO BE AMENDED. IT TO DO
PASSED TO BE AMENDED TO A PRO
AND APPROPRIATIONS MYSTERY-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RECREATIONAL VOTE COLLEGE THANK
YOU. MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE PAST TO BE
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS SB SEVEN
UP TO HUESO MORE LOCK BRADFORD
OUR BEDFORD I CHING CHANG AYE
DODD. DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL
HILL AYE MCGUIRE RUBIO SKINNER
STERN WIENER. EVEN ON MEMBERS
ONLY. YES WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
THAT MEASURE ON CALL AND WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THE COMMITTEE
OPEN UNTIL ARE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARE ABLE TO RETURN. YES WILL
OPEN IN. HORROR SENATOR CHIANG
ON THE MISSILES WILL STAR WOULD
ITEM ONE SB TO ALL THREE. OF
THE APPS ARE CONCERNED COUNTER
THAT. YES YES. ON THE CONSENT
ITEMS. SB YOUR THREE D. PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CHIANG I. TO
HOLD IT UP AND- A COUPLE. ITEM
NUMBER TWO HAS THREE THREE
SEVEN EIGHT THREE SEVEN EIGHT
WIENER DO PASSED TO BE AMENDED
IN SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO.
MOORLACH BRADFORD KING KING I
MCGUIRE SKINNER. SO THAT ONE
HAS ANNA OKAY AT LEAST. ON ITEM
THREE SB SIX OH FIVE OR CENTER
HUESO THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO CHIANG
CHING I MCGUIRE SKINNER AND
STERN. JERRY AND. SB THREE
EIGHT SEVEN WAS A NON VOTE FOR
WE HOPE THAT IN COMMITTEE SO.
AND THEN IT WOULD. YES SHE'S ON
EVERYTHING. AND WILL OPEN UP
THE ROLE FOR SENATOR RUBIO ON
HER MISTER ITEMS. CONSENT
CALENDA SB TWO OH THREE
BRADFORD. HI RUBIO HIGH. SHE
MISS. FOUR AM SB SEVEN A TO
HILL CURRENT VOTE FOUR ZERO
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE. AND THE-
THING THAT. YEAH TO GET SENATOR
WAS TOO STRONG YEAH. YES. THE
GOOD ONES ARE. WE TELL THEM
CORRECT OKAY
. WELCOME TO GIVE
US A RECESS AT THE GOVERNMENT
SAYS WELCOME GOD I APPRECIATE
IT WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE
FOR BOTH ARMS ARE ABSENT
MEMBERS SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
MORE LOCK AND WILL START THE
WIRES COMING TO YES. MCGUIRE IS
COMING IN- YES SKINNER SO YOU
GOT HERE. WELCOME IS AREN'T WE
USE. WE JUST WE JUST GOT THE
FIRST ELEVATOR ONCE WHERE YOU
WANT TO STE THE CASH NOW. WHEN
IT MIGHT SAVE YOU A LITTLE TIME
WE WAIT AKA. CIRCUIT CITY
. WE
DON'T JACKSON ALRIGHT WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE ROLE FOR ALL OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS WERE GONNA FOR
STAR WHAT ITEM ONE OR CONSENT
CALENDAR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS ON SB TWO OR
THREE CONSENT. CURRENT PHONE
NINE ZERO. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER. SB TWO OR THREE
CONSENT. WITH TWO OR THREE
CONSENT RATHER YOU HAVE TO WORK.
INNER I. IN A. WHO WE ARE THE
SOONER OKAY. OUR NEXT ITEM CHIU
SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT BY CENTER
WHERE YOU HAVE TO BE AMENDED
AND APPROPRIATIONS. NUMBER
EIGHT ZERO MARK NO MORE LIKE NO
BRADFORD. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER SKINNER I. YOUR VOTER
RANGERS AND. OKAY THAT SOUNDS
ALL RIGHT ITEM THREE SB SIX OH
FIVE FIVE ZERO HUESO. YEAH YES
I'M CERTAIN THREE SEVEN EIGHT
IS OUT SB SIX OH FIVE DAY
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS KIND
PHONE NINE ZERO MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN
STERN HIGH. YEAH THANK MEASURES
OUT ZERO EXCITING FOR SB SEVEN
OH TWO BY SENATOR HILL. HE
PASSED THE AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
FIVE ZERO HUESO MOORLACH MORE
LIKE AYE HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE AYE GRAY
AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN
STERN AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE.
NOT. AND THEN THE AND I DON'T
FIVE WAS HELPING COMMITTEE
NOBLE SIX. AND THEN YOU CAN
SAID. GEN WHETHER WE WANT TO.
YEAH NO. BUT ALL OF THIS
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE CONCERNED
GALLAGHER GAFFER ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB TWO OR
THREE STERN AYE STERN AYE.
EVERYTHING THAT'S OUT OF 12%
TWELVE ZERO. YEAH. MEETING
ENTER OR WE WOULDN'T. ALL RIGHT
BACK CLUED ARE ALL ITEMS FOR
ENERGY TO LOSING COMMUNICATIONS
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY FIFTEENTH
WE STAND ADJOURNED